Du bist ein Mensch, der die ganze Zeit von der Welt ausweicht.
An der Kraftwerkerkellungsmelodie kann man es ja im Grunde schon ablesen. Es ist der letzte Mittwoch im Monat und das heißt, der Blue Moon auf Ritz wird heute Abend zum Chaos Radio für drei Stunden mit dem Studio vom Chaos Computer Club Andreas und Tim und meine Person Max Formalotki. Und bevor wir anfangen, müssen natürlich erst mal die Prämissen geklärt werden. Deswegen möchte Tim gerne Folgen des Credo verkünden.
Ja, also wir berichten live aus dem Irak. Wir sitzen in einem Hotel, dessen Namen wir natürlich nicht nennen dürfen, um uns selbst nicht zu gefährden und auch um die eingebetteten Truppen, die wir eingebettet sind, nicht zu gefährden. Und dafür müsst ihr natürlich Verständnis haben, aber dafür ist alles wahrhaftig, live, direkt und in 3D.
Sind wir authentisch?
Natürlich.
Wir sind echt, 100 prozentig echt. Das heißt, dass die 80. Sendung, die ja heute Abend eigentlich eine lustig-schunkelige Jubiläums-Sendung hätte werden sollen, so ein bisschen umfunktioniert wird. Denn es gilt sich zu unterhalten über das Thema Krieg im Irak und vor allen Dingen das Thema Medien und Medienmanipulation. Wo wollen wir denn so ungefähr hin heute Abend, Andreas?
Ja, wir wollen darüber reden, wie Medien sich während dieses Krieges verhalten und wie Medien auch manipuliert werden, natürlich von beiden Seiten und dazu benutzt werden, um die Stimmung in eine bestimmte Richtung zu treiben oder militärische Ziele zu erreichen. Solche Sachen, also wir gucken, wie wird manipuliert, warum wird manipuliert und wie das Internet auch die Informationslage dabei verändert hat.
Und da sollt ihr natürlich dabei sein in Berlin und Brandenburg und möglichst mitdiskutieren beim Chaosradio heute Abend, der 80. Ausgabe. Das Ganze natürlich erst mal über Telefon. 0331 77 97 1 1 0 ist die Nummer und wir haben mehrere Flagen hier mal aufgeschrieben.
Wir haben natürlich noch vorher noch einen Hinweis an Frank. Frank, die gegnerischen Truppen haben Portfilter installiert und wir haben Probleme derzeit mit unseren Kommunikationsmitteln durchzukommen. Und wenn die Jammer abgeschaltet sind, dann ändert sich das vielleicht und du wirst es dann auch merken.
Ja, und wir dürfen den Reaktor natürlich nicht filmen hier in Bagdad. Und wir sagen auch nicht, welcher Reaktor das sein könnte. Ja, die Einstiegsfrage für den heutigen Abend, Tim. Ich würde, du hattest vorhin noch mal so nachgedacht und gebrummt. Als ich sagte, wo informiert ihr euch primär, wäre ja eine schöne Einstiegsfrage. Da meintest du, nee, nee, nee. Und dann beschäftigst du dich aber weiter mit Kabeln im Fußboden. Deswegen sind wir gar nicht dazu gekommen, das zu klären.
Ja, also Fragen. Ich meine, alle, denke ich, haben so in den letzten Wochen mehr oder weniger Zeit damit verbracht, die Berichterstattung zu verfolgen. Und vielleicht sind euch ja bestimmte Widersprüchlichkeiten aufgefallen in dieser Berichterstattung, die halt irgendwie nicht sein können. Und wenn solche Widersprüchlichkeiten euch aufgefallen sind, dann würden wir darüber gerne hören, mal einen Start zu haben.
Ja, 0317797110. Irgendwelche Widersprüchlichkeiten entdeckt in der Berichterstattung, zum Beispiel mal bei der ARD geguckt. Da hat der Reporter gesagt, hier in Bagdad geht es gerade mega mäßig ab. Hier fallen die Bomben. Dann mal rübergeschaltet zu ZDF. ZDF, es ist total ruhig hier in Bagdad und wir sind natürlich live auf der Antenne. 0317797110. Und damit ihr euch erstmal zum Telefon schleichen könnt, Musik von Andreas Laptop. Ja, wir können dich alle hören. Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir haben es kurz nach 10, das heißt die Sendung hat gerade erst angefangen und das 80. Chaosradio wird sich heute Abend ein bisschen mit Medien und Medienmanipulation im Krieg beschäftigen. Und ihr könnt unter 031 77 97 110 mitmachen. Und zwar vielleicht ist es euch ein bisschen aufgefallen, der Krieg geht ja jetzt schon den 7. Tag oder was war das?
Ja, heute ist, nee, ja doch.
Heute Nacht ist es läuft gegangen.
Da kann man ja sehen, wie man will, wie lange der schon läuft. Also eigentlich läuft er mindestens schon zwei Wochen, würde ich sagen.
Oder Jahre oder Jahrtausende.
Ja, also auch schon konkret dieser Krieg, würde ich sagen, hat auf jeden Fall einige Tage eher begonnen, als das so offiziell wahrgenommen wurde. Weil das halt schon vorher Truppen in Irak war, das war ja, wie soll ich sagen, da gab es doch durchaus Hinweise und man weiß auch, dass eigentlich so eine Operation nicht eingeleitet wird, bevor man nicht mindestens ein paar hundert Leute im Land hat, die halt schon mal die potenziellen Angriffstile ausgespäht haben. Das hat man ja gesehen. Der erste Schlag ging halt sehr gezielt an einen bestimmten Ort. Ich glaube, es war ein Hotel sogar oder zumindest eben ein vermuteter Treffpunkt irgendwelcher höheren Funktionäre. Ich schätze mal, dass sie durchaus davon ausgehen konnten, dass vielleicht Monsieur Saddam da auch persönlich anwesend war. Das wäre für sie natürlich der optimale Erfolg gewesen, ihn gleich sozusagen mit einem Schlag wegzuhauen. Nur, wo kommt diese Information her? Die muss ja schon mal generiert worden sein. Also die waren da schon länger.
Das ist nämlich auch die Frage jetzt klar für das Fernsehen. Für die Masse der Medien hat der Krieg vor sieben Tagen angefangen. Und das ist nämlich auch der Punkt, dass die Medien im Grunde bestimmt, wann dieser Krieg angefangen hat. Weil vorher ist er ja nicht wirklich sonderlich aufgefallen. Und was ist euch aufgefallen bei den Medien, wo ihr gesagt habt, Moment mal, was sie da erzählen, kann doch nicht stimmen, ihr habt doch vorhin da das gehört oder das gehört. Was ist euch aufgefallen, wo es nicht ganz klar war in der Berichterstattung, was da gezeigt wurde? 0331 77 97 110. Im Studio Andreas, Tim und Max. Und ihr habt ja eine Menge natürlich auch verfahren, was das anbelangt, was man so an kleinen, das kann ja eigentlich so nicht gelaufen sein, Geschichten erzählen kann.
Ja, vielleicht können wir gleich mit dem Angriff anfangen. Es ist vielleicht dem einen oder anderen aufgefallen, dass vorher viel davon erzählt wurde, ja, und irgendwie werden in der ersten Nacht 1000 Bomben schmeißen, dann war gar nichts. Das lag daran, dass sie quasi einen Tag angefangen haben, bevor sie anfangen wollten, weil sie wussten, wo sich der Vize-Premier Aziz aufhält und möglicherweise auch noch andere. Und woher wussten sie das? Indem ein Gerücht gestreut wurde, und zwar auf einer Website namens debka.com, die geheimdienstnah, israelisch geheimdienstnah ist, wurde das Gerücht gestreut, dass Aziz desertiert wäre. Das wurde dann erst von rechten amerikanischen Medien, später von allen internationalen Medien aufgenommen als Gerücht. Und irgendwann war es soweit, dass Aziz eine Pressekonferenz geben musste, um zu dementieren. Und auf dem Weg von der Pressekonferenz nach Hause wurde er halt verfolgt und es wurde festgestellt, in welchem Bunker er sich aufhält. Und die Gelegenheit wollten die Amerikaner nutzen, um dazu zu schlagen. Das heißt, da wurden gezielt die Medien manipuliert, mit dem Zweck, das herauszufinden, wo er sich befindet. Also ging es gar nicht um die Information der Öffentlichkeit, sondern nur, da wurde das Medium quasi benutzt zu Kriegszwecken.
Aber was so was anbelangt, wie eine Reaktion zu provozieren. Ich meine, Saddam Hussein wird ja auch dauernd vor den Kameras gezeigt, also von den Kameras gezeigt in seinen eigenen Networks und dadurch auch in den anderen in der ganzen Welt. Kann man dann nicht vermuten, dass der Typ von vornherein schon 120 Videobänder mit allen möglichen Dementis, die vorkommen...
Eieiei daneben.
Ja, nee, kannst du ruhig aufsetzen und darfst nur den...
genau.
Haben sie dir keinen Kopfhörer gegeben?
Nein, keinen Kopfhörer, kein Internet und keinen Stuhl.
Tim ist schon ein bisschen dröppelig. Kann das nicht sein, dass Saddam Hussein da für den Fall sowieso schon 120 Videokassetten aufgezeichnet hat mit allen Dementis, die es so geben könnte und dementsprechend dann schon gegen so eine Methode vorgehen kann?
Na zum einen ist es so, dass Saddam Hussein ihnen in der Regel sowieso vorproduzierte Bänder zeigt und nicht live zu irgendeiner Pressekonferenz geht. Und auch das Band, das unmittelbar nach den ersten Angriffen gezeigt wurden, hat sich ja nicht direkt auf die Ereignisse bezogen, konkret, sondern es war nur sehr abstrakt. Und da kann man schon vermuten, dass das von einem Tape kam, dass es nicht live war.
Okay. 037797110, wenn euch ähnliche Fälle untergekommen sind, bei denen ihr Medienmanipulation oder schlechte Informiertheit vermutet oder denkt, hey, das passt aber so und so vom Schluss nicht zusammen, ruft an beim Chaosradio bei Fritz. Am Telefon ist der Toni aus Eberswalde. Hallo, Toni.
Ja, hallo.
Na, was sind dir für Widersprüche ausgefallen?
Also ich hab ja das Gespräch schon von Anfang an mitbekommen. Und dort würde ich gerne gleich eins aufgreifen, das war, wo der Präsident Bush diese Anweisungen her hat für diesen Anschlag. Also dass es jetzt zum Beispiel losgehen soll, dass vom Geheimdienst eben zugetragen worden sein, dass es dort ein bestimmtes Zeitfenster gibt, wo Saddam Hussein angeblich ja irgendwie angegriffen werden kann mit Bomben und man wusste höchstwahrscheinlich in diesem Zeitraum genau, wo er sich auffällt. Und aufgrund dieser Information hat halt Bush diesen Staat eingelötet vom Krieg. Und das hat ja auch in seiner Ansprachsrede so geäußert mit dieser Floske ein Zeitfenster. Das hat er übrigens damit gemeint.
Ja, also ich meine, das wissen tun wir das natürlich nicht, wo die Information herkommt, aber man kann natürlich davon ausgehen, dass sie auch innerhalb des irakischen Militärsystems unter Umständen ihre Spitzel- und Doppelagenten haben. Das können wir jetzt nur vermuten. Das ist durchaus eine Quelle. Darüber hinaus hören natürlich die Amis auch extrem den gesamten Telefonverkehr ab. Inwieweit sie jetzt innerhalb der Kommandoebene der Iraker über ausreichende Verschlüsselungssysteme verfügen, um sich da komplett zu schützen, darüber könnten wir jetzt auch nur spekulieren.
Na gut, aber eine andere Sache, die mir eigentlich noch aufgefallen ist und wo ich auch eigentlich drauf hinweisen wollte, ist diese Satelliten-Telefone, die ja diese Korrespondenten vor Ort haben, funktionieren ja normalerweise direkt über Satelliten, sodass ja eigentlich eine qualitätsarme Übertragung gewährleistet ist. Aber diese Satelliten, diese Satellifone, die dort eingesetzt werden, die haben regionale Basen vor Ort, die von den Amerikanern dort aufgestellt wurden. Und diese Frequenzstörungen, die man im Nachrichten oder in irgendwelchen Magazinen sieht, basieren eigentlich darauf, dass die Amerikaner dort die Frequenztöne regional verändern bzw. an- und ausschalten, sodass während des Militärangriffs es nicht gewährleistet ist, dass diese Korrespondenten irgendwas über die Lage berichten können. Und besonders ist mir aufgefallen bei der Korrespondenten Antonia Rados. Dort war das sehr, sehr häufig. Und immer wenn direkt Angriffe waren, konnte man sequenzielle Störungen feststellen, sodass man nicht direkt hören konnte, was diese wirklich sagt. Und das habe ich herausgehört durch einen Militärexperten, der danach dann geantwortet hat, weil sich der Moderator so gewundert hat, hat gesagt, na können denn solche Störungen auftreten durch Bombardements? Und dort sagte der Militärexperte, nein, nein, das ist so, dass dort regionale Basen aufgestellt werden, wo dann halt mal der Schalter betätigt wird von den Amerikanern, wenn Informationen fließen, die nicht wirklich fließen sollen, während dieses Momentes.
Ja, da gibt es auch noch eine Bestätigung für, also das gestört wird. In dem Fall waren es nicht Telefone, sondern Fernsehsender. Und zwar wurde das irakische Fernsehen gestört, während Saddam Hussein seine Rede gehalten hat, direkt nach den Angriffen. Das heißt, es konnte terrestrisch gezeigt werden im Irak, aber die Satellitenübertragung war gestört.
Naja, ich meine, jetzt haben sie auch schon militärisch gegen Informations- oder Kommunikationsbasen irgendwelche Anschläge oder Bombardements verübt. Und ich meine, das wird natürlich bewusst unterdrückt. Aber ich meine, man muss sich ja auch mal vorstellen, dass sich eigentlich der Normale, da ich das jetzt mal so betone, sich eigentlich normalerweise nicht darüber wundert, ach, da ist mal das Bild weg und dann ist mal das. Aber das sind ja sozusagen planmäßige Instrumentarien, um eine Art Inszenierung auch dabei zu führen. Und das ist, weiß ich nicht, das sollte man gar nicht so einfach hinnehmen. Ach, dann ist doch mal was so. Sondern, ich weiß nicht, das sollte man vielleicht doch etwas mehr verfolgen. Da, wenn man sich schon vorstellt, dass dort einige Informationsfilter mal bei sind, erst vor Ort, Herr Großpodent, dann geht es zu irgendeinem Sender, denn eine Agentur muss es bestätigen, dann muss es auch noch dementilfrei sein. Keiner darf was dagegen sagen, während die, also nicht die Iraker und nicht die USA. Und dann erst kommt es objektiv zu dem Konsumenten. Und das ist ja eigentlich eine Unmöglichkeit, dass der Konsument nur ein Quäntchen von Wahrheit davon erhaschen soll. Und das ist ja tatsächlich, das weist auf meines Erachtens auf eine planmäßige Inszenierung.
Na ja, das steht natürlich vollkommen außer Frage, dass das alles planmäßig inszeniert ist. Die Amerikaner haben mehrere tausend Leute, die mit nichts anderem beschäftigt sind, als weltweit die Verbreitung der von ihr gewünschten Informationen zu fördern. Da gibt es komplette generalstabsmäßig organisierte Gruppen, die das einfach professionell hauptamtlich betreiben. Und natürlich haben die kein Interesse daran, dass jede Information ungefiltert rauskommt, weil sie einfach genau wissen, wie sehr ihr ganzer Waffengang natürlich davon abhängt, dass sie von einer Öffentlichkeit unterstützt werden. Und zwar natürlich vor allem der amerikanischen Öffentlichkeit. Das hat sich gezeigt an dieser Sache mit den Bildern der gefangengenommenen amerikanischen Soldaten. Aber natürlich auch der Weltöffentlichkeit. Und da tun sie natürlich genauso alles, wie sie auf dem Startfeld alles tun.
Ja, das ist ja richtig. Nur ich sehe das Problem darin, wenn man das so erkennt und so als offiziell auch aufnehmen kann. Denn sehe ich es ja als hohen an, wenn die Amerikaner das als die größte Errungenschaft sehen des Informationszeitalters, dass Information sozusagen frei zugänglich ist und eingebettete Journalisten ja hautnah dokumentieren können, ja fast zum Unterhaltungsfaktor wird als wirklich. Und solche Bilder, wie sagt El-Jazeera, was man ja leider nicht empfangen kann, weiß ich nicht, dort werden Bilder natürlich nicht gezeigt, weil Genfer Konvention oder so. Aber ich bin fast der Meinung, dass man solche authentischen Bilder, wenn sie auch, sag ich mal, psychologisch nicht gerade gesund sind, wenn man diese übermäßig konsumiert. Aber man sollte sie, denke ich, mal einfach zeigen, damit man mal das Wahrgesicht dieser ganzen Angelegenheit bekommt und nicht nur irgendwelche, ja, Animationen und ja, irgendwelche...
Also ich meine, das ist ein interessanter Punkt, so gerade mit diesen Reportern, was du da ansprichst. Dass das so dargestellt wird, dass das eine Errungenschaft ist, da brauchen wir glaube ich gar nicht drüber reden. Selbstverständlich, was sollen sie sonst sagen? Aber der eigentliche problematische Punkt dabei ist vor allem, diese Reporter sind halt jetzt schon seit Wochen dort im Irak, sind von vornherein halt, wie das eben so schön heißt, eingebettet. Das ist eigentlich ein echt schöner Begriff, finde ich so. Kann man sich also ordentlich vorstellen, wie sie da ordentlich Downkissen von links und rechts irgendwie auf die Ohren und auf die Augen am besten auch noch gedrückt bekommen. Das Hauptproblem ist, dass sie natürlich Teil der Truppe werden und jeden Tag das erleben, was die erleben und damit sozusagen ganz automatisch, das lässt sich gar nicht verhindern, solidarisch werden mit der Gruppe, sich als Teil von ihnen verstehen und natürlich jederzeit irgendwie Informationen, die vielleicht für eine Berichterstattung auswählenswert wären, einfach weglassen, weil es könnte ja ihre Jungs gefährden. Das würden sie so nie sagen, aber das ist auf jeden Fall der Fall.
Naja, genau das, was Sie gerade erwähnen, das habe ich auch schon mal als Kritikpunkt gehört und diese Journalisten haben eigentlich gar nicht mehr so die Hemmung davor, das auch zu äußern. Also die besonders, die zum Beispiel auch Flugzeugträgern sind, die sagen auch eindeutig, dass sie keine Geheimdienstinformationen preisgeben dürfen, die als solche halt ausgegeben sind. Sie dürfen keine Koordinaten durchgeben, wo sie sich genau aufhalten. Und der dritte Punkt war durch noch irgendwas, also keine direkte Übertragung während, ach genau, wenn und welche Geschosse abgefeuert werden, dürfen sie auch nicht direkt auf Bord sein, sondern müssen dann unterdeckt sein.
Den Kollegen Jay Tuck zum Beispiel, das ist der, der dir für die Tagesthemen berichtet, den haben wir auch im Programm interviewt. Und das ist ja der, der auch immer wieder behauptet, ja, wir dürfen den Reaktor nicht filmen, wir dürfen nicht bei den Planungssitzungen dabei sein und so weiter, wir dürfen nicht sagen, wo sich der Flugzeugträger genau jetzt befindet, wo seine genaue Position ist, ansonsten dürfen wir frei berichten. Ja klar, aber das Ding ist ja, wenn du irgendwo, manwewegen du bist in deiner Klasse unterwegs, in der Schule oder du bist bei der Arbeit, wenn irgendwelche Leute hinter deinem Rücken irgendwas machen wollen, da kann es ziemlich lange dauern, bis du irgendwie merkst, was dir überhaupt abgeht. Wenn jemand anderes nicht will, dass du das überhaupt mitbekommst, hast du da nicht wirklich die Chance. Und diese Geschichte mit den eingebetteten Reportern, du musst schon eine verdammt coole Sau sein, wenn es dir scheißegal ist, dass um dich rum Granaten, Kugeln und so weiter splittern und du willst den objektiven Blick auf die Dinge behalten, während dir der schweiß die Kimme runterläuft und du irgendwie vielleicht gerade von dem Typen, der da neben dir steht, gerettet worden bist. Das ist also meiner Meinung nach unmöglich.
Also meinen Sie, auf den Flugzeugträgern ist jetzt eine Gefahr dort zu richten?
Nö, das nicht. Aber dafür haben die da auch nicht so die Informationen, die so kickig sind, dass es irgendwie relevant wäre.
Also meines Achtens sind die da eigentlich fast überflüssig. Also ich würde eher bevorzugen direkt im Kriegsgebiet, aber da ist es ja nun noch gefährlich. Also die Journalisten, die bewegen sich ja schon immer auf gefährlichen Torrenten und ich glaube, das wissen sie auch. Und was mir jetzt in dem Zuge auch gleich einfällt, die heutige Nachricht mit Al-Jazeera an den Börsenmärkten. Ich meine, ich finde ja verblüffend, wie sie denn immer noch die Ausrede finden, dass es eigentlich nur damit zu tun hat, dass ein Sender nicht mehr frei ist und eine Frequenz nicht mehr vorhanden ist für diese Journalisten. Also ich weiß nicht.
Das muss man glaube ich nochmal erklären, was es mit der Nachricht auf sich hat, für die, die es nicht gehört haben. Es ging darum, dass der Sender Al-Jazeera an der New Yorker Börse nicht mehr arbeiten darf, sind da rausgeschmissen worden, weil ja Al-Jazeera Bilder von toten amerikanischen Soldaten gezeigt hat.
Und übrigens auch ein krasses Bild, was man hier auch nicht im Fernsehen gesehen hat. Dort sollen sie sogar, wofür sie sich auch noch entschuldigt haben, 12 jedes Kind gezeigt haben mit einem halben Kopf. Ich meine, das sind natürlich dann schon Sachen, die dann doch etwas pervers sind. Aber ich meine, irgendwie so krass es klingt, aber ich glaube, so sieht es dann... Ich meine, das sind Ergebnisse. Ich meine, wenn man einen Krieg beobachtet von irgendeiner, wie sie so sagen, bemannten Kamera, also mir kommt es so vor wie in der Truman Show, da ein bisschen so überall bemannte Kameras auf Blickpunkte, die genau analysiert werden können und die bekannt sind. Und dann sieht man dort irgendwie so eine abstrakten Bilder von irgendwelchen Geschehnissen. Und meines Erachtens, und darauf wollte ich jetzt noch hinaus, und zwar ist mir aufgefallen, dass die Amerikaner möglichst bemüht sind, abstrakte Bilder zu bringen. Also zum Beispiel durch Nachtsichtkameras, ist ja klar, nachts hat man wahrscheinlich keine andere Technik, aber das auch erreicht wird vor Ort, diese Videokameras. Was man könnte ja eigentlich vor Ort mit einer etwas hochauflösenden Kammer, die das ganze Geschehen aufnehmen muss, will man die Details natürlich irgendwie vertuschen sozusagen.
Na gut, da geht es natürlich vor allem um die Live- und Schnellberichterstattung. Die haben jetzt alle irgendwie digitale Systeme, die das direkt auf den Satelliten hochschicken. Und da kriegen sie natürlich jetzt nicht beliebige Bandbreiten, inwieweit da noch höhere Qualitätsstufen zu erzielen wären. Da kann ich jetzt nur drüber mutmaßen, das ist sicherlich vorstellbar. Und irgendwo haben sie da sicherlich auch eine Grenze. Auf der anderen Seite sind natürlich die Medien auch an guten Bildern interessiert. Aber das ist schon eine technische Limitierung auch.
Und Toni, da jetzt die Nachrichten gerade vor der Tür stehen, und wir jetzt halb elf haben, wollte ich dir soweit erstmal danken. Und da kann man natürlich abschließend nochmal sagen, dass möglicherweise, wenn es diese Bilder so wie die Amerikaner sie geben, nicht gäbe, diese ganzen virtuellen Sachen und die ganzen Leichen gezeigt werden und die ganzen Kinder mit den halben Köpfen und die andere Hälfte vom Kopf fliegt da, vielleicht klar werden würde, dass eben nicht die Medien pervers sind, sondern der Krieg. Aber das wollen die ja nicht.
Wenn Fritz rundum hält sich, dann 91, 9 22.31 Uhr.
Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht erwarten uns leider Gottes immer mehr Wolken bei Tiefstwerten zwischen 5 und 2 Grad. Morgen bleibt es wolkig, es gibt auch immer wieder mal Schauer. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 12 bis 16 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Berner. Die alliierten Truppen haben am Abend wieder die irakische Stadt Bagdad bombardiert. Reporter berichten von heftigen Explosionen in der Innenstadt. Im Laufe des Tages hatten alliierte Flugzeuge in Bagdad eine irakische Luftabwehrstellung unter Beschuss genommen. Laut dem US-Zentralkommando lag sie mitten in einem Wohngebiet. Zum Zeitpunkt der Bombardierung gab es in Bagdad eine Explosion in einer belebten Geschäftsstraße. Dabei wurden mindestens 15 Menschen getötet.
Noch ist allerdings nicht hundertprozentig sicher, dass die Explosion und die Bombardierung unmittelbar miteinander in Zusammenhang stehen.
Südlich von Bagdad stoßen die alliierten Truppen nach wie vor auf heftigen Widerstand. Die Lage ist für sie extrem gefährlich, Christian Fock berichtet.
Wieder sind US-Truppen aus dem Hinterhalt beschossen worden. Wie Reporter berichten, wurde bei Nasseria im Südirak ein Nachschubkonvoi mit Granaten und Gewehrfeuer angegriffen. Auf amerikanischer Seite soll es keine Opfer gegeben haben. Derartige Vorfälle reißen nicht ab, denn aufgrund des offensichtlich hohen Tempos der vorrückenden Kampfverbände bleiben immer wieder sogenannte Widerstandsnester hinter dem Frontverlauf übrig. Schwere Gefechte gab es um eine Brücke über den Olfrad heute weiter nördlich bei Najaf. Einige Soldaten gelten noch als vermisst.
Techniker des Roten Kreuzes haben die Wasserversorgung im südirakischen Basra teilweise wieder in Gang gebracht. Allerdings stehen nur etwa die Hälfte der Menge zur Verfügung, die vor Kriegsbeginn gebraucht worden sei.
Basra hat schon seit Tagen kein sauberes Trinkwasser.
Hilfsorganisation zufolge besteht solchen Gefahr. Der Terrorverdracht gegen Islamisten aus Berlin-Neukölln hat sich offenbar verstärkt. Laut dem Tagesspiegel hat ein Tunesier möglicherweise geplant, mit einem Flugzeug einen Sprengstoffanschlag zu verüben. Bei der Razzia in der letzten Woche sei ein Flugsimulator, eine Chemikalienliste und ein Liter Batteriesäure gefunden worden. Der Verdächtige befindet sich zurzeit in Untersuchungshaft. Und zum Sport in der zweiten Fußball-Bundesliga hat Union Berlin in einem Nachholspiel gegen Reutlingen 0 zu 0 gespielt. Und der Verkehr auf Fritz, wir haben aktuell keine Meldung, deswegen gute Fahrt.
Bollmann, die Fritz Börse. Hier kannst du suchen.
Gebrauchten Farbfernseher.
Eine Doppeltouch.
Bieten. Ja, ich hab so einen Powermax Bauchtrainer.
Staubsauger, der hat 1200 Watt.
Tauschen.
Zwei Karten fürs Retro Chili Peppers Konzert.
Und Wiedersehen.
Ich suche den Jungen, der beim Konzert direkt vor mir stand.
Bollmann, die Fritz Börse. Immer Samstag, immer von 12 bis 14 Uhr. Und im Radio.
Wir hören das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Drei Stunden Talk, wir haben jetzt noch zwei Stunden 20 Minuten ungefähr davon. Thema heute Abend in der 80. Ausgabe des Chaosradio Medien und Krieg, Medien Manipulation und Krieg. Ihr könnt mitmachen unter 073 97 110 im Studio Andreas und Tim und Max. Vielleicht noch mal kurz eine kleine Einführung ins Thema. Ja, was wir bis jetzt alles so abgehakt haben.
Ja, wir besetzen uns wie alle irgendwie mit dem aktuellen Kriegsthema auseinander. Aber wir wollen halt nicht irgendwelche Dinge kommentieren, sondern wir wollen kommentieren, wie kommentiert wird und werfen einfach einen Blick auf die Berichterstattung, die ja natürlich jetzt ganz neue Maße angenommen hat, auch im Spiegel der modernen Technologien. Also auf der einen Seite haben wir natürlich neue Technologien in der konkreten Kriegsführung. Das ist ganz offensichtlich, dass die Amerikaner ja Arsenal nochmal sichtlich aufgebessert haben und sie prallen ja nicht zu knapp mit rum, wie toll sie jetzt Menschen umbringen können. Und natürlich haben auch die Medien nachgerüstet. Das sieht man an den Live-Übertragungen aus anstürmenden Panzern. Da sitzen die dann halt mit Satelliten, Videofeeds, Kameras, die halt einfach das Bildsignal direkt digitalisieren und live irgendwie zu einem Satelliten schicken, von wo es dann halt sofort weiter distributiert und dann eben direkt in die Fernsehkanäle eingespult wird. Eine ähnliche Sache mit deutlich höherer Qualität sind die feststehenden Kameras, die eben von diversen Nachrichten Agenturen in Bagdad und leider eben auch nur in Bagdad installiert wurden, wo es dann halt immer diese super spannenden Bilder so. Und wir schauen jetzt nochmal nach Bagdad. So, und dann sieht man also im besten Fall vielleicht noch eingeblendet irgend so einen Menschen, so einen hilflosen Reporter, der keine Informationen hat und dann irgendwie ein bisschen berichten möchte und dann auch immer so, als würde jetzt gleich die Tomahawk vorbeifliegen, sich dann auch immer noch kurz bevor er antwortet, nochmal so nach hinten umdreht. Und ja, ich sehe, es ist jetzt gerade etwas. Nein, es passiert gerade nichts, aber man dreht sich nochmal um. Aber nein, es passiert immer noch nichts. Also es ist wahrscheinlich ruhig. Permanent kommentieren sie das total nichts, weil sie ja eigentlich keinerlei wirklich nennenswerte Informationen haben. Aber sie müssen halt irgendwie Airtime füllen. Und das ist irgendwie das, wie das alles funktioniert.
Ja, ich finde es ja auch sehr bemerkenswert. Die Kameras, die man gesehen hat in der ersten Nacht, die standen ja nicht irgendwo, sondern die standen auf dem irakischen Informationsministerium. Und ja, muss man sich natürlich schon fragen, was ein Informationsministerium denn für Interesse dran hat, dass da unabhängige Berichterstattung passiert. Also, was da aus diesen Kameras rauskam, den kann man, glaube ich, auch nicht beliebig viel trauen. Es gibt da Anekdoten von Leuten, die auf dem einen Fernsehsender das Livebild aus Bagdad gesehen haben und da war es dunkel und auf dem anderen Fernsehsender gab es auch ein Livebild aus Bagdad und da war es schon hell. Und so richtig nachvollziehen kann das keiner. Und es gibt auch Leute, die nicht direkt in den normalen Fernsehsendern fernsehen gucken, sondern die große Schüsseln im Garten haben und sich auch mal Sachen angucken, die nicht jedermann sofort sieht. Satelliten-DXer, also nach Long Distance Radioamateuren benannt, die auf den Fernsehsatelliten nach Programmen suchen, die da eigentlich gar nicht da sind, sondern die bloß Zuspieler sind, wo dann halt die Bilder kommen, wo man dann den Stream, der da aus Bagdad kommt, live und ungeschnitten sieht. Und wo man auch Al Jazeera zum Beispiel sehen kann, also auf Astra. Jeder, der einen 60 Zentimeter Astra-Schüssel hat, kann Al Jazeera gucken hier in Europa. Ist also empfangbar.
Und das ist jetzt aber nicht so die einfache Übung, wo ich dann sage, ich drücke hier auf den Knopf und damit habe ich das Programm. Da muss man schon einiges an Geschick aufweisen, wenn man das machen möchte, oder?
Ach, es gibt glücklicherweise im Netz Seiten, auf denen dokumentiert ist, wo diese Feats laufen.
Wir haben da ja, ich kann ja mal den Telefonhörer in Betrieb nehmen.
Ja, das können wir.
Es gibt da eine Website, eine für mehrere, aber eine interessante Website, dxandy.de. Diesen dxandy, den buchen wir jetzt auch mal an. Dort finden sich fertige Settings für D-Boxen, die mit diesem DV2000 heißt es, richtig?
DVB2000.
DVB2000OS, diesen gehackten OS für die alte D-Box ausgestattet sind, sodass man sich sozusagen fertige Kanal-Settings direkt unterladen kann in die Box und dann gleich alle Feats hat. Aber dazu kann der junge Mann gleich sicherlich noch sehr viel sehr viel detaillierter Auskunft geben, als ich das jetzt hier aus dem Kopf kann.
Ich wähle hier einfach mal. Und gucke mal, ob er zu Hause ist. Hallo, Fritz hier, Chaosradio. Guten Abend.
Hallo DxAndy.
Ja, guten Abend.
Ich habe hier gerade die ketzerische Frage gestellt, wie das alles überhaupt funktioniert. Und da gibt es offensichtlich Webseiten, auf denen das alles steht. Und dann wurde aber sofort umgeschwenkt und gesagt, das kann DxAndy alles viel besser erklären, wie man sich so ein Feed auf seine heimische Schüssel holt, sozusagen. Würdest du da vielleicht mal so einen kleinen Ansatz wagen wollen?
Ja, gut, also man benötigt ein Spiegel. Ich sag mal 1 Meter, 1, 20 Meter wäre schon zu empfehlen. Vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr. Einen digitalen Satelliten Receiver. Vorzugsweise die D-Box 1 mit DVP 2000. Das ist eine Alternativsoftware drauf.
Wo gibt es eigentlich die Software?
Die gibt es zum Beispiel bei mir auf der Homepage www.dxandy.de zum Download. Und dann noch die entsprechenden Informationen, wo, wann was läuft und so weiter. Und dann stellt man halt den Spiegel auf den entsprechenden Satelliten. Und kann dann sich die Feeds da reinziehen.
Du hast ja jetzt in den letzten Tagen auch dich ein bisschen damit beschäftigt, die für die Irak-Berichterstattung relevanten Feeds, Satellitens Feeds, ein bisschen zu herauszusuchen.
Richtig.
Und hast auch glaube ich fertige Settings auf deiner Homepage dazu.
Exakt, so ist das. Man kann diese Settings, was nichts anderes als Kram-Tabellen sind, die von der Homepage downloaden und sich dann in seine D-Box spielen, beziehungsweise auch in andere Satelliten, da gibt es dann genug Komplettierungstools. Ja, da spielt man sich die rein und spart sich dann halt die Arbeit, dann eben da erst neu einzulesen, irgendwelche Daten einzugeben, die sich aus dem Internet holen sollen, man spielt das einfach ein und ja, zappt die Feats dann halt durch. Ja, in den vergangenen Tagen war der Satellit heute unser BR. Sehr aktiv ist er.
Oh, da hacken die USA sich gerade wieder in das Handynetz rein wahrscheinlich. Na, die Handynummer hab ich anrufen, weil ich mir nicht sicher war. Entschuldige. Aber wir hören dich, glaub ich, wieder, Andi. Ja?
War ich irgendwie eine Spörung oder was?
Ja, du warst kurz weg.
Bist ein bisschen geschwankt. Sie kommen dich zu holen.
Auf welchen Satelliten sieht man denn da die meisten Feats und wie findet man die eigentlich?
Ja, also das ist, also jetzt ganz aktuell und ganz viele Feats sind drauf auf diesem Satelliten-Euten-Satellit W1. Der ist auf 10 Grad Ost zu finden. Ja, wie man die findet, ja gut, es ist im Allgemeinen bekannt, in der Szene, sage ich mal, auf welchen Satelliten zu diesen Zeiten verstärkt Aktivitäten sind. Da gibt es eine sehr gute Homepage, das ist www.lynxsad.com. Da werden weltweit, im Prinzip gibt es da eben so Satellitenkriegs, die da ihre Feats und Aufschaltungen und was sonst so alles gibt, auf Satelliten, die das entdecken und dann dorthin melden. Und man kann dann eben auf diese Homepage gehen und sich da erstmal von Daten herholen. Ja, und wie gesagt, aktuell ist ja 10° Ost der W1 sehr stark belegt. Da gibt es verschiedene Kamps, die da draußen, die dann eben 24 Stunden rund um die Uhr eben auf eine ernstbestimmte Stelle dort in der Stadt zeigen, in Bagdad und so weiter. Aber dann gibt es eben auch Feeds, wo jetzt die übertragen für ARD, ZDF und so weiter und auch für arabische Sender und so, die dann eben dort abgestrahlt werden. Und die Stationen ARD, ZDF, Sat1, RTL und was sonst was alles gibt, die holen sich das dann von dort eben.
Wie viele Live-Camps hast du gefunden?
Ja, also jetzt auf dem 10° Osten sind es aktuell also zwei, die ständig drauf sind und dann noch, ich sag mal, drei, vier, die relativ oft von ARD sind.
Und sind da auch diese, die Leute, die jetzt irgendwie da auf den Embedded Journalists, die sind da nicht zu finden, die irgendwie extrem sind?
Die sind da nicht drauf, aber da hat man ja dann die Alternative, dass man dann auf den original Kanälen, wo denn diese abgestrahlt werden, also CNN und so weiter, dass man die dann eben auch empfangen kann, also über ASTER und HOTWIRT ganz einfach.
Aber nur, dass die versteckt sind, heißt also, dass die schwer zugänglich sind für den Normalbürger, heißt ja noch nicht, dass es authentisch ist, was da läuft. Wie sicher kann man denn davon ausgehen, dass das nicht auch was gefaktes ist?
Ja gut, also speziell bei diesen 24-Stunden-Kamps, da ist eben klar zu erkennen, dass da nicht irgendwie so eine Bildschleife oder was, wie es sich abläuft, sondern man sieht eben, wie es halt dunkel wird und so weiter. Also da sieht man auf jeden Fall rund um die Uhr, ob da nun irgendwelche Explosionen stattfinden oder eben nicht. Das, was die Sprecher dann dort erzählen, das mag vielleicht dann ein Text sein, der dann von denen so formuliert wird, so wie die das wollen, aber auf jeden Fall sieht man auf 10° Ost zum Beispiel eben zu 100% original Livecam-Bilder, die auch nicht irgendwie wie gesagt als Bildschleife oder was da laufen.
Al-Jazeera ist ja eigentlich so, wie heißt der andere Al-Arabia? Al-Arabica? Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht. Al-Arabia oder sowas. Das sind ja glaube ich so die gefragtesten arabischen Sender. Wo kriegt man die am einfachsten?
Ja, also der Al-Jazeera, der läuft seit ein paar Tagen auch auf dem, ich sag mal Volkssatelliten, auf diesen Satelliten namens Astra, der hat einen Spiegel als Normalsterblier auf dem Dach, der hat den eben angepeilt. Und da läuft der Al-Jazeera seit ein paar Tagen drauf. Und der, ja, wenn jemand die Frequenz durchsagen soll, falls da jemand von hinten dran... Ja, kann ich. Moment. Ja, das ist 11.580 V, also vertikal. Und die Symbolrate ist 22.000 und die FEC ist 5, 6.
Aber wie kommt denn das da drauf? Ich meine, so ein Sender kommt ja nicht automatisch irgendwie auf so einen Satelliten. Und ich nehme auch mal an, dass es bestimmte Leute gibt, die versuchen zu vermeiden, dass so was auf so einem Volkssatelliten jetzt auch ausgestrahlt wird. Wie kommt das da hin und wer entscheidet das?
Also, Astra, ich meine, die werden wahrscheinlich bei ihren Kunden, das sind ja alles Europäer, da gibt es jetzt durchaus den Bedarf, mal Quellen zu empfangen, die eben nicht aus Europa kommen, nicht aus den USA kommen. Das ist ja nun eigentlich...
Also, der Al-Zadirat, der ist auf so eine Art Fremdsprachen-Transponder aufgeschaltet worden, da ist noch so ein Kanal Algheri drauf und TV5 aus Frankreich, RTM aus Marocco, ESC1 aus Ägypten und so weiter. Also, das ist halt so ein Transponder, auf dem im Prinzip nur Fremdsprachen pro Gramm abgestrahlt werden. Und wie gesagt, genau dahinter steckt, wer nun das Geld dafür bezahlt, dafür die Aufstaltung von diesem Al-Zadirat, das kann ich auch nicht sagen, aber jedenfalls ist er da jetzt seit ein paar Tagen drauf und ist ja mal ganz interessant, nicht nur immer auf CNN gucken, sondern auch mal da reingucken.
Die Astra Leute werden einfach verstanden haben, dass es die beste Methode ist, die Leute sich für Astra zu interessieren, da jetzt Al-Zadirat drauf zu werfen. Da haben sie wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal was dafür, dass sie da drüber senden. Ja, super. DxAnni, wir danken dir ein bisschen. Und ein bisschen sehr und wünschen dir noch einen schönen Abend.
Alles klar, danke schön.
Bis bald.
Der Ho sagt gerade im Chat, dass der andere Sender Abu-Dhabi TV wäre.
Abu-Dhabi TV?
Es gibt auch noch alle Araber, die ich die ganze Zeit nicht aussprechen kann. Aber das ist halt überhaupt ein Phänomen, dass jetzt eigentlich die arabische Welt bei diesem Goldkrieg kräftig kontern kann. Vorher gab es einfach nur CNN und BBC World. Und jetzt gibt es halt mindestens einen weiteren, weltweit bedeutenden Sender. Und vor allem ist es natürlich jetzt auch so, so sehr die amerikanische Regierung Kontrolle über die in Amerika basierten Sender doch erlangen kann. Das sieht man ja gerade an den Ereignissen der letzten zwei Tage. So wenig Kontrolle haben sie natürlich über die Sender, die halt jetzt in der arabischen Welt verwurzelt sind. Das ist natürlich auch eines der größten Probleme, zumal die kritische, vergleichsweise kritische Öffentlichkeit hier in Europa, die nimmt das natürlich nun verstärkt wahr. Das ist ja nun eigentlich auch das, worum es geht. Sie sind insofern absolut begrüßenswert zu sehen, wie zum Beispiel die ARD- und ZDF-Berichterstattung. Also ich meine, sie überschlagen sich schon in der Wiederholung der Floskel mit Ja, und können wir denn das jetzt glauben und Nein, und woher kommt denn das, und das ist eine Quelle, da weiß man auch nicht so richtig und überhaupt. Und ich möchte nochmal anmerken, das sind jetzt so die offiziellen Zahlen von den Generälen, und da weiß man ja nie so genau. Also etwas, was einfach beim letzten Golfkrieg nie und immer so stattgefunden hat. Und jetzt fühlen sie sich schon geradezu genötigt, diese Medienkritik irgendwie mit rauszubringen, überhaupt noch Glaubwürdigkeit auszustrahlen. Weil, das hat eins, und RTL hab ich so den Eindruck, da ist dann doch eher noch so ein bisschen der typische Privatfernsehinstall am Start, und dann wird das auch alles noch so ein bisschen zelebriert, so in ihrer gewohnten Art. Und es gibt ohnehin noch keine Kultur für Quellenennung. Also nicht, auch wenn man jetzt, will ich das nicht kritisieren, aber wenn wir jetzt hier irgendwie die Nachrichten hören, dann heißt es ja, und 16 Leute werden noch vermisst. So, dann frag ich mich, wer vermisst die? Wer hat das gesagt? Wann? Warum? Und so. Klar, dass es in so einem kurzen Newsblock nicht ohne Weiteres mit rein zu werfen ist, und auch nicht unbedingt jetzt immer von Interesse ist. Nur, es wird halt in der Regel eigentlich nie getan.
Da kann man natürlich mal erzählen, wie das passiert, weil, wenn man da schon mal drauf anspricht, das sind natürlich sehr kurze Nachrichten, und da gibt es auch eine Philosophie, die dahinter steckt, wenn solche Nachrichten gemacht werden, gerade eben bei den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Es ist so, dass bei manchen Sendern, ob das nun Fernsehen oder Radio ist, oder ob das auch eine Zeitung ist, oder was auch immer, meistens sind die Schnellmedien sehr daran interessiert, dass es so ist, dass wir verschiedene Feeds, also verschiedene, sag ich mal, zulaufende Meldungen bekommen, wie in so einem Ticker. Früher gab es das mit so einem Schreiberling, das kam dann aus so einem Drucker raus, jetzt ist es im Internet oder irgendwo anders. Und wir haben halt verschiedene Sachen, wie zum Beispiel DPA, Deutsche Presse Agentur, dann gibt es noch AFP und so weiter, und davon gibt es Hunderte. Und dann meldet irgendeine von diesen sogenannten Agenturen, das und das und das ist da und da passiert. Und dann gibt es eben halt Sender, die sozusagen an der schnellen Meldung interessiert sind, und die sagen dann sofort, wir haben hier gerade eine Meldung hereinbekommen, Bagdad ist komplett bombardiert worden, und fünf Minuten später können sie das wieder dementieren, weil irgendwelche anderen Leute sagen, das ist Quatsch, bzw. sich niemand anders und keine andere Agentur sich dazugesellt. Hier ist es glaube ich so, wenn ich da unsere Nachrichtenredakteure mal richtig verstanden habe, dass wir abwarten, bis mindestens drei oder vier seriöse Agenturen die gleiche Meldung herausgeben, um wenigstens zu wissen, dass es sich da wahrscheinlich um eine Sache handelt, weil die Agenturen ja auch nochmal filtern und gucken, dass ihre Quellen das nochmal sagen.
Also es ist zumindest mal eine Mehrheitsmeinung, in Anführungsstrichen handelt.
Ob man sich darauf verlassen kann, ist eine andere Sache, aber es ist zumindest schon mal ein Filter dafür, dass nicht der allergrößte Quatsch erzählt wird. Also nur damit man mal weiß, wie sowas bei den Nachrichten funktioniert. Das müsste man natürlich, wenn man korrekt ist, in den Nachrichten immer wieder sagen, das haben die und die und die Agenturen zu diesem und diesem Zeitpunkt gemeldet. Aber irgendwann würde das Ganze wahrscheinlich da nicht mehr verdaulich sein, wenn man es vor allem im Radio hören und verstehen will.
Wo es natürlich immer noch so ist, dass da die Nachrichten trotzdem gemacht werden können, weil die Agenturen ja auch voneinander abschreiben und das nicht unbedingt überprüfen können. Und auch solche Agenturen natürlich manipuliert werden können auf die verschiedensten Arten und Weisen.
Ja, voneinander abschreiben.
Sehr beliebt ist immer der Trick, Journalisten mit Informationen anzufüttern, die dann größtenteils richtig sind. Und gelegentlich ist dann mal so ein Häppchen dabei, das einfach bloß gestreut werden soll, was der Journalist dann halt auch berichtet, wo dann quasi als Injektionsquelle in die in Anführungszeichen seriösen Medien benutzt wird. Und gerade in Kriegszeiten ist sowas ja auch schwer zu verfolgen, weil da so viel auf einmal passiert und so viel gleichzeitig passiert, dass man liest das dann und ob das dann war oder nicht, wenn hinterher was anderes rauskommt, das wird man schon gar nicht mehr wahr. Und es nimmt sich ja auch keiner die Zeit, das alles zu recherchieren, bei jedem einzelnen zu gucken. Wo kommt das jetzt her? Wer hat das zuerst gesagt? Wo ist es zuerst aufgetaucht? Zumal die meisten Leute ja auch gar keinen Zugriff auf die Tickernachrichten haben und gar nicht überprüfen können, was in den Tickern gesagt wurde. Sondern die ließen nur das, was dann von den Redaktionen verdaut und abgedruckt wurde. Und das ist dann also noch mal eins mehr gefiltert.
Tim und ich wundern uns gerade extrem, weil hier parallel der Fernseher läuft und auf MTV, eine Comicserie, läuft. Normalerweise soll man ja nicht auf Sekundärmedien verweisen, weil dann sofort alle umschalten. Aber merkwürdigerweise kann man da gerade mal reinhören.
Da sieht man gerade eine F-16, die einen Stealth-Bomber bekämpft.
Das ist ja der Hammer.
Und den Zeichentrick.
Ja, der ist aber nicht zu schlagen.
Da ist jetzt ein Flugzeugträger.
Ja, wir berichten ja live aus Bagdad. Wir haben hier gerade einen Einbruch in unseren Luftraum.
Sag mal, was ist das denn?
Das ist Animationen für Kinder. Das ist Jugendprogramm in Kriegszeiten. Und das ist natürlich auch sehr passend.
Oh, da sieht man gerade einen AVEX. Das ist das, womit wir so viele Probleme haben in der Türkei. Also dieses wunderbare Überwachungssystem, wo die Deutschen eigentlich nicht nach rechts gucken dürfen, da wo die Grenze der Türkei ist und da wo die Kurden alle warten, im Nordirak. Großartig. Ja, so viel zur Propaganda. Wobei MTW sich ja auch Mühe gegeben hat, so ein bisschen über den Krieg ansatzweise zu reflektieren, wenn ich das zwischendurch richtig gesehen hab. Ich hab das nicht unbedingt geschaut, aber das ist ja so gerade echt der Hammer.
Es gibt einfach so viele Facetten, man kann gar nicht alles aufzählen. Was ich z.B. auch extrem bemerkenswert fand, war vor ein paar Tagen war ja diese Oscarverleihung, oder was? Sonntagnacht. Genau, also Sonntagabend. Zu meiner persönlichen großen Überraschung wurde ja der Oscar für das beste Dokumentationswerk an Michael Moore verdient. Michael Moore ist derjenige, dessen Buch Stupid White Man die Bestsellerlisten in den USA anführt. Und mindestens hier in Deutschland scheint auch sein Film Bowling for Columbine ein echter Knudder zu sein. Im Zentralkino läuft er jetzt irgendwie schon seit Monaten. Das wird ich in einem Kino, was eigentlich normalerweise keinen Film monatelang zeigt. Zur Erinnerung, der Film geht halt so über diese Waffenverliebtheit der Amerikaner und auch so irgendwie generell über ihre Paranoia. Und jetzt hat er doch tatsächlich den Oscar bekommen und ist dann mit seiner Dankesrede kraftig nach vorne gestürmt und hat irgendwie voll draufgehalten. Shame on you, Mr. Bush, shame on you. We're doing a fictitious war for fictitious reasons. Und wir sind einfach interessiert in Non-Fiction. Der ist im Prinzip auch genau diesen Punkt, der eigentlich Wahrheit an der Stelle mit thematisiert hat. Danach hat er noch mal eine kleine Nachpressekonferenz gegeben, wo er diese Thesen auch noch mal bekräftigt hat. Und er macht das ja auch aus einer, wie soll ich sagen, einer Bürgerhaltung fest. Er versteht sich ja als Amerikaner, als Aufrechter und möchte das Land vor seinem Präsidenten retten und gehört eben jetzt nicht zu der Fraktion, die am liebsten ausreisen würden. Davon gibt es, glaube ich, auch eine ganze Menge gerade. Wie auch immer.
Ich kann ja mal kurz schauen, weil ich glaube, ich hab den Michael Mutoh nämlich gerade noch mal gefunden. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, welcher das genau ist, warte mal.
You probably noticed there was no fancy red carpet.
Name.
Wir sind gegen diese Krieg, Mr. Bush.
Schade an dir.
Das ist die Frage, die ich jetzt schon immer habe, was ich jetzt hier so gerne so gerne was wir jetzt eben gehört haben war er hat geredet also klar also einerseits haben sich irgendwie jetzt die Leute die das organisiert haben erstmal bemüht da die Musik rein zu ziehen.
Das Orchester kam sofort dazu.
Ja ja genau so irgendwie Gott oh Gott und nicht dass er noch schlimmere Sachen erzählt und dann hat man auch relativ stark die Buhrrufe gehört. Jetzt war es aber so, wenn man sich die Bilder angeschaut hat, hat man einfach niemanden buhen gesehen. Der Punkt war gebuht haben da irgendwie die Saaldiener, die alle schön möglichst nahe an den Mikrofonen standen. Und danach in der Nachpressekonferenz hat er auch noch mal gefragt worden, naja es haben ja auch Leute irgendwie Buhrgerufen. Da meinte er, naja ich hab die Szene ja gesehen irgendwie. Da waren die meisten Leute haben irgendwie geklatscht und haben vielleicht ein paar Leute Buhrgerufen. Schreiben sie jetzt bloß nicht, die Hälfte hätte gebuht und die andere Hälfte nicht. Ja und danach bin ich mal ein bisschen durch die Webseiten gegangen, die Berichterstattung da drüber, über Google News, Michael Moore, da gab's dann irgendwie Links auf alles Mögliche und es war also unfassbar, wie unterschiedlich sozusagen dieser Event dargestellt wurde. Also sehr viel so Washington Post, la la la, meinten halt so ja und er wäre halt ausgebuht worden und gemäßigte Rezonen konnten das halt irgendwie noch so halbwegs in Relation setzen während eben an der Stelle auch halt auch nicht seine Worte wiedergegeben wurden, während halt Postillen in Kanada und natürlich die Webblogs das irgendwie eins zu eins wiedergegeben haben. Und auch an der Stelle merkt man eben auch wie diese Selbstkastrierung der Medien einfach so ein Standard ist. Also die haben einen eingebauten, vorauseilenden Gehorsam in diesem ganzen patriotischen Wahn, der ist einfach gefährlich.
Aber ist das nicht, also ich frage mich immer, ist das in Amerika dann, ist das in Amerika stärker vertreten als hier oder findet man das hier auch?
Na ja gut, ich meine ich bin mir sicher, würden wir jetzt irgendwie hier in einen Krieg ziehen, was wir nun Gott sei Dank nicht tun, dann wäre natürlich auch hier so eine Welle der Selbstmobilisierung und Schollklappen so und Gott jetzt Augen zu und durch und Hauptsache schnell vorbei. Ich meine, das hat man auch gesehen, als Deutschland ja im Prinzip im letzten Golfkrieg auch involviert war. Auch Bosnien, da sitzt man da und denkt sich, lass es nur schnell vorbei sein und oh Gott, jetzt haben sie schon wieder einen Bus getroffen und so, ja Kollateralschäden, morgen ist vielleicht vorbei. Also man wünscht sich ja sozusagen, dass es auch so schnell wie möglich vorbei geht. Ich denke, bei den USA kommt noch deutlich mehr hinzu, weil sie halt einfach so eine Mars-Nation sind, so in ihrer eigenen Sprache.
Ja, aber wenn ich mir die eine oder andere Bild-Zeitungsschlagzeile angucke, drängt sich mir auch der Verdacht auf, dass da schon ein Versuch wird, eine Tendenz zu erzeugen, so Überschriften, die versuchen, den Eindruck zu erwecken, als hätte Saddam Hussein den Krieg angefangen. Das ist mir echt aufgefallen in den Tagen, bevor es losging.
Ja, auch N24 zeigt also seit Wochen diese ganzen Waffen, Detailberichte, Irak, Golfkrieg von letztes Mal, Reportagen, seit Wochen.
Das Lustige ist auch, wenn man sich nur mal die Überschriften anguckt, die die verschiedenen Nachrichtensender für das gesamte Thema wählen. Ich glaube, bei NTV ist es so, die nennen das ganze Krieg gegen Saddam, also wirklich fixiert auf die Person dieses Diktators. Dann gibt es welche, die sagen Krieg im Irak, dann sagen welche, es gibt Krieg gegen Irak und sowas prägt einen natürlich auch, weil wenn man das oft genug guckt, denkt man, okay nur Saddam ist schuld, Saddam ist der Böse, der ganze Irak ist schuld, wir befinden uns im Irak, das ist alles doch ein bisschen schlimmer, da ist die Bevölkerung dabei oder nicht, sowas impliziert natürlich auch immer was. Aber wir haben es gerade drei Minuten nach 11. Das Chaosradio auf Fritz, noch zwei Stunden mit Andreas und Tim und meiner Person Max. Heute Abend geht es um Medien und Medienmanipulationen in Sachen Irakkrieg, was uns momentan alle betrifft und noch betrifft und was leider wahrscheinlich auch so schnell nicht vorbei sein wird. 031 77 97 1 1 0 ist die Nummer. Was ist euch in diesem Zusammenhang aufgefallen, was in Irakkrieg und Medienmanipulationen anbelangt? Seid ihr zufrieden mit den Medien, wie sie euch bedienen? Ist euch vielleicht irgendwie das eine oder andere aufgestoßen? Habt ihr da mal was geguckt und gesagt, das kann doch so nicht sein, das habe ich doch da gerade anders gesehen oder was ist das überhaupt? Zieht ihr euch deswegen komplett raus? Das ist der Fragenkomplex, der uns heute Abend beschäftigt. Deswegen, wenn ihr mitreden möchtet, 031 77 97 1 1 0, das 80. Chaosradio steht für euch offen. Und am Telefon ist der Frank.
Hallo, ich muss vorab sagen, ich bin einer von diesen so genannten 120 Bürgern in Deutschland, die sich erlaubt haben, Herrn Schröder und die Bundesregierung anzuzeigen. Und was mich stört jetzt an den Medien ist, bis auf ein paar kleine Artikel, z.B. im Fokus oder im Tagesspiegel, wird darüber gar nicht berichtet. Dass praktisch unser Grundgesetz praktisch massiv verletzt wurde.
Kannst du mal sagen, worum die Klage ging?
Ja, und zwar bin ich der Meinung, dass die Bundesregierung indirekt sich an diesem Angriffskrieg beteiligt. Aber was war die Klage? Ich habe eine Anzeige gemacht gegen Artikel 26 Grundgesetzverletzung und Strafprozess Paragraph 80.
Das ist 18 und 80 Asen doch dieses Anheizen zum Angriffskrieg und ähnliche Sachen, oder?
Genau, und ich bin halt der Meinung, indem man den Amerikanern hier Überflugsrechte gewährt, indem man praktisch Personal freistellt, was Kasernen bewacht, unterstützt man praktisch die Amerikaner, indem die ihre Personalien dann anderwertig einsetzen können, indem man die AVEX, also ich meine, ich weiß nicht, was die Gerichte da jetzt, der Verfassungsgericht da gesehen hat, aber irgendwo kann man mir doch nicht erzählen, dass das Radar oder diese Überwachungssachen da an der türkischen Grenze auf immer wie bei einer Wand hi-hat machen und da keine Angriffe von den Deutschen da mit koordiniert werden. Das ist vor allem ein Unkurs.
Ja, das Radar macht sicherlich keinen Halt. Die Frage ist natürlich, was die Crew konkret tut. Ob die konkret Angriffseinsätze unterstützt oder ob sie das eben nicht tut.
Ja, bloß, das ist ja im Mischepersonal. Das sind ja keine reinen deutschen Flieger, sondern das hier im Mischepersonal. Und will man mir erzählen? Ich meine, ich hab bei den Amerikanern selber gearbeitet. Ja, als West-Berliner irgendwo.
Wo hast du da gearbeitet und in welcher Position?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das euch ein Begriff ist. Nee. Also das war so eine Wachpolizei, rein deutsch. Und wir haben die Kaserne praktisch in West-Berlin bewacht von den Amerikanern.
Nur ist diese Geschichte mit der Türkei und den AVEX natürlich eine Sache, die unter NATO-Befehl stattfindet. Und deswegen ist die Frage, ob da Deutschland so die richtige Adresse ist. Und da müssen vielleicht andere Leute darüber entscheiden.
Ja, bloß ich bin der Meinung, bloß weil man Angst hat, politisch, dass die NATO-Platz unser Grundgesetz auszuheben, ist so ein starkes Stück. Und davon miss ich einfach die Medien. Ich sage einfach hier mit nichtsen, die Medien haben ja praktisch nichtsen aus weißer Haus geschrieben. Irgendwo, wenn die Medien sich mehr dafür einsetzen würden, dass nicht immer laufend unser Grundgesetz aufs Massivste beschädigt wird. Mir fällt da vor, ich meine, das ist dagegen ja harmlos, irgendwo der Kohl mit seinen Spendenaffären ein. Und jetzt, wie ihr sagt, beteiligen wir uns indirekt an so einem Krieg. Irgendwo, das ist eine Augenwischerei von der früher Regierung. Irgendwo, die sagen, die machen nicht am Krieg mit, aber indirekt beteiligen wir uns doch irgendwo.
Nun haben die ja gesagt, für den Fall, dass die Türkei sich tatsächlich entschließen sollte, da etwas massiver im Nordirak einzumarschieren, um sich da etwaige Fründe zu sichern, dass dann die deutschen Soldaten da abgezogen werden müssen.
Da hab ich den Schili aber schon wieder anders verstanden. Der hat das relativiert, indem er einfach gesagt hat, naja, die sind da schon seit Jahren da drinnen irgendwo und man soll mal die Kirche im Dorf lassen. Ich meine, was ist unser Grund hier selbst wert, wenn das Laufen verletzt wird?
Na ja, wenn das Laufen verletzt wird, dann ist es sicherlich wenig wert, allerdings. Ich weiß nicht, es ist natürlich jetzt auch eine Ansichtssache. Ich meine, ich habe schon den Eindruck gewonnen, das ist jetzt auch eine persönliche Meinung, dass es eigentlich kaum eine Regierung auf diesem Planeten gab, die sich so sehr gegen diesen Krieg gewendet hat, wie die Deutsche ihr sozusagen unter den Umständen dann vor allem volle Kriegshetzerreize unterstellen, halte ich für schwierig vermittelbar.
Aber Völkerrechtsexperten sagen doch auch, dass praktisch dieser Krieg ein rechtswidiger ist. Wenn er ein rechtswidiger ist, dann dürfen wir den Amerikanern keine Überflugsrechte geben, oder?
Ja gut, aber die Diskussion ist ja noch nicht wirklich zu einem Ende gekommen und die haben ja versucht, das im Sicherheitsrat vorher zu klären. Ich finde ja eher, dass Deutschland sich relativ weit aus dem Fenster gelehnt hat, was die Ablehnung dieses Krieges anbelangt. Wenn man mal überlegt, was es so für internationale Konflikte hervorgerufen hat, da hat Schröder schon ganz schön viel gewagt für seine Verhältnisse, finde ich. Und ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht mehr wiegt, als diese möglicherweise Verletzung der Grundrechte, wo man auch schon sehr, sehr genau gucken muss, um das eigentlich zu belegen, oder?
Ja, bloß da muss er. Ich bin ja mal, der sollte die letzte Konsequenz gehen und aus der NATO austreten. Und die amerikanischen Basen in Deutschland und Europa geschlossen werden.
Okay, aber dein Punkt war ja im Prinzip, dass über die Klage als solche wenig berichtet worden ist. Also ich meine, wer hat es denn aufgegriffen und wer hat es explizit deiner Auffassung nach nicht aufgegriffen?
Also ich muss sagen, Ausschlag geben, für mich war ein kleiner Artikel im Tagesspiegel, wo auch nochmal diese Punkte aufgelistet wurden, wo praktischen Staatsrechtler gefragt wurden, wo allerdings auch drinne stand, dass so eine Klage eigentlich für einen Arsch ist, um das mal so einfach zu sagen, ja. Und bloß ich hab mir gedacht, als Bürger, ich muss da einfach auch mal Flagge zeigen, weil ich nicht so ein Typ bin, der gerne irgendwo demonstrieren geht. Ich wollte das einfach anders machen. Ich hab mir gesagt, ich mach da jetzt eine Klage. Ich meine, Schröder ist für mich klar auch...
Nicht dass es eine Anzeige?
Eine Anzeige, ja. Klar ist Schröder für mich in dem Moment eigentlich auch der Falsche, weil er eigentlich meine Sache ja vertritt, der dagegen kriegt. Bloß indirekt irgendwo sage ich, da muss er aber auch den zweiten Schritt gehen und sagen, wir unterstützen die Amerikaner in keinster Weise. Und die können wie es ich irgendwo per Beamstrahl nach dem Irak fliegen, aber nicht mehr über Deutschland. Das ist meine Meinung irgendwo.
Es kann ja auch durchaus sein, dass Schröder darauf spekuliert, dass das tatsächlich vor dem Bundesverfassungsgericht diskutiert wird, damit er sozusagen nach außen hin sagen kann, ja, ich würde ja gerne mit euch, aber wir haben da diese Verfassung und ich wurde dazu gezwungen, wir müssen uns jetzt doch zurückziehen. Das kommt einfach nach außen hin auch anders rüber, als wenn er von sich aus sagt, nö, wir machen da nichts. Internationale Politik ist immer sehr, sehr schwierig. Und das, was auch wenn unser Bundeskanzler ist, ist er dann auf internationaler Ebene schon wieder einer von 200 Staatsführern. Und da was zu bewegen, ist halt oftmals kompliziert. Und ich denke auch, dass Schröder schon getan hat, was er tun konnte. Und ehrlich gesagt bin ich auch ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass jetzt nicht die Konsequenzen ergriffen wurden, die Überflugrechte zu verbieten, die LX-Besetzung abzuziehen und so weiter und so fort. Aber wissen wir denn auch, wie die internationale Lage ist? Also, ob wir es uns als Deutschland überhaupt erlauben können, das zu tun oder nicht? Und wie für uns als Land die Risiken dabei sind? Das ist halt immer so eine Frage.
Ja, aber puh, wer weiß, ob dann die Amis nicht dann sagen, ach, dann fliegen wir halt einfach so über Deutschland, mal gucken, was die machen. Solche Sachen können da mal passieren. Also ich glaube als Politiker, der in solchen Bereichen unterwegs ist und Schröder geht der Arsch wahrscheinlich sowieso schon ziemlich auf Grundeis, willst du nicht noch alles riskieren, was du möglicherweise zu riskieren wäre?
Ja, bloß dann würden die Amerikaner ja ihr Wort sich zeigen. Ich denke mal, dass die Regierung eine Faschistische ist.
Also ganz ehrlich, ich glaube nicht, dass gerade eine AVEX in der Türkei für die Amis ein sehr großes, wichtiges Ding ist. Zumal es ja nun überhaupt gar keine Nordfront gibt und von dort sicherlich auch Flugzeuge starten, aber es gibt einfach auch eigentlich überhaupt keine Luftgegenwehr des Irak. Also es ist halt einfach so eine Sache. Ich verstehe zwar, dass du das irgendwie anklagen möchtest und sozusagen noch eine etwas radikalere Haltung eingenommen sehen möchtest. Allerdings müssen sie natürlich auf internationaler Ebene eine ganze Menge ablegen.
Wir könnten natürlich mal eine Spekulation bringen. Vielleicht ist es ja so, dass die natürlich wissen, dass diese Jungs da in den AVEX Flugzeugen, also die Deutschen in der Türkei, dieses Problem bringen. Aber vielleicht sind die auch gerade der Anker, die es Deutschland ermöglichen, der Türkei zu sagen, hey Leute, ihr lasst mal schön eure Finger da draußen, weil unsere Jungs sitzen in den AVEX und dass das eine Art politisches Druckmittel ist, um die Türkei aus dem Nordirak rauszuhalten.
Auf jeden Fall. Das sehe ich eben.
Das könnte sowas sein.
Kann ich kurz noch mal was einwenden? Ich meine, wir haben ja auch eben noch kurz von der NATO geredet. Ich weiß nicht, ob euch das bekannt ist, die Drogtriden der NATO wurden doch praktisch auch von den Amerikanern auf Druck der Amerikaner geändert, dass wir jetzt ein Angriffsbündnis sind und kein Verteidigungsbündnis mehr. Ist doch richtig, ne?
Oh, da steck ich leider so tief nicht drin. Das kann ich jetzt weder bestätigen, noch dementieren, sag ich mal. Das kann ich leider jetzt nicht sagen.
Ich denke mal, dass ich das vor einer Weile im Fokus mal gelesen habe, dass da irgendwo so auf Drenken der Amerikaner praktisch, die mit ihren Erstschlachtmentalität, also die NATO, da voll einwickeln wollen.
Das kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen, weil sonst hätten die mit der Türkei jetzt nicht so eine Probleme, weil es genau um die Frage nach dem Angriff geht. Aber das geht jetzt sehr, sehr tief rein, Frank, und weil wir bestimmt noch mal über andere Sachen reden wollen heute Abend, würde ich dir hier erst mal danken für deinen Anruf. Ihr könnt anrufen unter 0877 97 110, wenn ihr euch an der Debatte beteiligen wollt heute Abend im Chaosradio. Andreas, Tim und Max sind hier bei Fritz im Studio und wir reden über Medien und Medienmanipulation im Irakkrieg und driften dann hin und wieder auch mal so ab wie gerade.
Genau, vielleicht können wir einfach auch noch mal ein paar andere Sachen beleuchten. Wir sind jetzt so ein bisschen auf diese deutsche Position gekommen, aber uns geht's ja eigentlich wirklich um die Berichterstattung als solche und wie die eben beeinflusst wird. Wenn man sich die amerikanische Berichterstattung anschaut, sieht man auch die deutsche, wie ich finde, sieht man, dass der arabische Blick auf das Problem eigentlich nicht wirklich beleuchtet wird. Also in den USA gar nicht so. Und hier ist es sicherlich verbesserungswürdig. Weil es wird wenig erwähnt. Irak ist halt einfach eine uralte Kultur. Da gibt es irgendwie Städte, die sind einfach älter als alles andere auf diesem Planeten. Das ist im Übrigen auch für die Amerikaner gerade bei ihrem Feldzug auch ein echtes Problem, dass sie einfach so bestimmte Bereiche nicht so ohne Weiteres mal bombardieren können, weil sie sich ja dann im Prinzip gleich auf Taliban-Augenhöhe gegeben, die mal eben die Statue in Afghanistan weggebombt haben. Und ähnliches droht denen natürlich auch. Aber das ganze Bild, was halt einfach geliefert wird in der Berichterstattung, ist eben immer bloß nicht auf das schauen, was in irgendeiner Form wirklich die Augen öffnen könnte. Und das ist eben das Problem. Aber es gibt halt auch noch einen neuen Trend, weil wir haben uns jetzt eigentlich sehr aufs Fernsehen bezogen. Ich beziehe meine Informationen in den letzten Tagen eigentlich primär aus dem Internet. Ich schaue natürlich auch Fernsehen, auch um das ein bisschen vergleichen zu können. Aber ich hatte das ja vorhin schon mit dem Beispiel mit dem Michael Moore. Insofern ist es ein interessanter Anschluss an die letzte Radiosendung, die wir jetzt hier auch hatten, zu dem semantischen Web und das Phänomen der Webblogs. Neben den klassischen Web-Nachrichtenquellen, die als erstes einfallen, BBC World, CNN, hier in Deutschland natürlich vor allem Spiegel Online und diese anderen Newsportale, hat sich eben auch diese Webblog-Gemeinschaft als Nachrichtenquelle ganz hervorgetan, aus verschiedenen Gründen. Erstens ist das Publizieren von Informationen am Webblog, also eine Art persönliche Seite, wo eine einzelne Person pro Tag eine oder mehrere Nachrichten hinstellt und die sich dann eben auf dieser Seite entsprechend chronologisch sortiert, immer wieder präsentieren. Und auch mit der Möglichkeit, spezielle Clients davon zu unterrichten, dass neue Nachrichten da sind, dieses RSS-System. Dadurch kann man das halt einfach sehr effizient lesen. Ich verfolge also so 10, 20 verschiedene solche Webblogs, die sich eben auch teilweise extrem dem Irak-Thema zuwenden. Warte, das hörte ich auch schon bei der Sendung. Da gibt es dieses warblogs.cc, was halt so ein Portal ist für verschiedene andere Blogs, die sich halt ausschließlich dem Kriegsthema wenden. Man nennt das jetzt schon Warblogging. Das ist schon innerhalb weniger Tage so ein eigener Begriff geworden. Es gibt dann auch noch diesen besonderen Fall des unter dem Pseudonym Salam Paks bekannten Menschen, der so hat es ganz den Eindruck, offensichtlich direkt in Bagdad sitzt, dort Internetzugangsmöglichkeiten hat, wenn auch nicht regelmäßig, sondern das bricht auch mal zusammen und dann eben seinen Weblog postet. Vielleicht mal die UAL für die Leute, die das interessiert. Jetzt muss ich allerdings...
Also ich hab's noch in meinem Kopf, glaube ich.
DeerRaid. Hört mal.
HTTP ohne WGW. Also HTTP www.dairrad.blogspot.com Wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche.
Ich überprüfe es mal kurz. Genau, DeerRaid, also dearunterstrichraid.blogspot.com Also einfach eine interessanterweise in den USA gehostete Seite. Und ich wundere mich am meisten, dass es die überhaupt noch gibt. Dort findet man halt immer Updates zu dem Thema. Es gibt dann halt auch noch diverse andere Blogs, die sich eben auch so äußern. Und das Gute ist, man kann in dem Webblog-System Nachrichten auch danach bewerten, wie sie von anderen Leuten aufgegriffen werden. Das heißt, bei Google für das Suchen wichtige System des Rankings, wer linked auf wen, das hat man eben hier direkt und selber erklicktbar. Und wenn man sich eben regelmäßig in diesen Webblogs aufhält und die Nachrichten vergleicht, wer berichtet was über was, bekommt man einfach sehr viel Hintergrundinformation, sehr viel andere Sichtweise.
Vor allen Dingen, wir haben ja mal einen Blue Moon gemacht über Wahrheit, auch im Chaosradio, wo es dann darum ging, dass die normalen, klassischen, althergebrachten Medien im Grunde immer versuchen, als sowas wie objektiv zu erscheinen. Und so ein Weblog möchte ja eigentlich überhaupt nicht objektiv sein. So ein Weblog sagt, hey, das ist mein Text, das bin ich, der das schreibe, ich bin das, der das schreibt, und das, was ich da schreibe, denke ich so. Das ist eine Meinung. Und dadurch, dass man weiß, dass es eine Meinung ist und dieses Weblog das auch explizit zu gibt, weiß man irgendwann, okay, der Typ denkt so und so und so. Und wenn der das Scheiße findet, dann könnte ich das vielleicht gut finden. Oder man sucht sich halt jemanden, der ähnlich denkt. Und man kann sowas vielleicht viel eher vertrauen als irgendwas, was behauptet objektiv zu sein und es aber per se gar nicht sein kann oder ist. Sehr spannende Geschichte auf jeden Fall. Also ich hatte gerade noch mal geguckt bei uns. Wir werden das im Laufe des Tages noch online stellen morgen. Wir hatten heute morgen kurz über Weblogs auch berichtet. Da sind auch mal so fünf, sechs, sieben Adressen aufgelistet für alle, die sich dafür interessieren, weil die doch immer ein bisschen schwierig zu merken sind. Das sind meistens nicht so die eingegangenen Adressen.
Man merkt auch, also Weblogs sind auch jetzt nicht nur so ein Undercoverthema, sondern es wird auch von den Medien schon berichtet. BBC World unterhält einen Weblog aller ihrer Reporter. Das ist eher mehr so Rückblickens, Zusammenfassungen, nicht so die Primärinformation. Es gab dann auch noch so einen Fall, der vor ein paar Tagen ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit erregt hat von einem Kevin Seitz. kevinseitz.net ist das, glaube ich, der im Nordirak war und angefangen hat dort über Telefon- und Satellitenverbindungen ein eigenes Weblog zu unterhalten, vor allem mit Fotos. Hatte halt irgendwie eine Kamera dabei und hat eben die Fotos. Also war nichts Besonderes, waren ein paar ganz interessante Informationen, aber es machte so einen Eindruck, als könnte es nochmal interessant werden. Und dann stellte er das Weblog ein, weil CNN ihn darum gebeten hätte, das zu tun. Es gibt dann verschiedene Verschwörungstheorien, warum das jetzt stattgefunden hat. Die einen sagen, naja, Mundtot macht ein Lalalala. Das andere war, dass er eben einfach eigentlich für CNN gearbeitet hat und dass die eben nicht wollten, dass er noch einen parallelen Newsfeed aufmacht. Ich weiß nicht, ob sich das so noch innerhalb dieses Krieges klären wird, warum. Aber es ist auf jeden Fall interessant, dass Leute das tun. Und es gibt vor allem viele Unabhängige, die jetzt gar nicht Journalisten sind, sondern die jetzt eigentlich erst zu Journalisten werden. Da gibt es diesen einen, das heißt schon wieder den Namen nicht parat, ich suche es gleich nochmal raus, der vor zwei Wochen angefangen hat, Leute aufzurufen, ihm Geld zu spenden. Und wenn er 10.000 Dollar zusammen hat, dann fliegt er in den Irak. Und gestern hat er die 10.000 Dollar zusammen gehabt und befindet sich jetzt gerade auf dem Weg nach Istanbul. Oder ist jetzt gerade da, das wissen wir gerade nicht. Genau, die URL ist backirak.com Und wir werden nochmal versuchen, ihn anzurufen. Ob das gelingt, das können wir natürlich jetzt noch nicht sagen.
Ich glaube, das ist der Kollege, der auch Mitinitiator war bei warblocks.cc. Das ist dieser All-Britain oder so, wie der heißt, glaube ich. Der Typ, der, ich schwimme gerade ein bisschen. Also, ist nur das, was ich im Hinterkopf hatte. Der war glaube ich auch schon mal da. Der war glaube ich auch schon mal da. Und deswegen heißt das auch Back to Iraq, weil er eben halt da schon mal Reporter war und für irgendwie Daily News aus London oder so was berichtet hat, glaube ich. Also der ist wirklich ein professioneller Reporter auch gewesen. Und der jetzt eben halt, wie gesagt, was Tim erzählt hatte, mit Mitteln, die er gespendet bekommen hat, zurück wollte, um da unabhängige Berichterstattung betreiben zu können. Da ist natürlich die Frage, inwieweit kann so jemand überhaupt das machen? Weil wenn hier zum Beispiel diese Sache mit den Satellitentelefonen, wie kriegt er da einen Internetanschluss? Wie will er da überhaupt was schreiben, wenn er sich irgendwann mal sehr weit in Irak reingewagt hat? Wie will er denn da überhaupt noch rauskommen mit Informationen?
Ich weiß es nicht. Na gut, rauskommen kann er natürlich irgendwie mit einem Satellitentelefon, das hat er dabei. Damit kann er halt irgendwie Daten absetzen und Internetverbindungen aufbauen. Und fürs Blogging braucht man ja nicht viel. Da kann man das ja alles offline erfassen. Das heißt, er schreibt das einmal, er braucht eben nur so einen kurzen Verbindungskonnekt, irgendwie um schnell mal die Daten alle hochzuladen. Und 10 absetzte Text, was schon sehr viel Berichterstattung ist, ist in 0, 0 nichts übertragen, selbst wenn noch ein Foto dabei ist, die 10-20 Kilobyte, das macht den Kohl nicht fett. Ja, der Typ heißt Christopher Allbritton und ist aber auch Reporter früher für AP und New York Daily News. Und er war wohl im Nordirak bereits, also außerhalb des Bereiches, der jetzt von Saddam Hussein noch kontrolliert wird. Und jetzt möchte er halt irgendwie wieder zurück. Und das tut er jetzt wohl gerade und muss man halt mal sehen, ob wir ihn erreichen. Bin mir noch nicht ganz so sicher, ob es klappen wird.
Ob wir ihn nachher mal erreichen per Telefon meinst du? Genau. Gut, 073 97 1 1 0, die Nummer von Blue Moon, ist eine Talksendung hier, das Chaosradio heute Abend. Deswegen sollt ihr euch auch beteiligen.
Wir wollen ja auch noch was von euch wissen.
Eben, weil die ganz spannenden Geschichten erfährt man ja meistens immer nur so. Und deswegen existiert das hier ja auch, abends auf Fritz, weil ihr wahrscheinlich sowieso tausendfach mehr Geschichten kennt, als wir das hier tun. Am Telefon ist der Wetterfrosch, Namen Wetterfrosch.
Genau. Ich wollte noch mal ergänzend sagen zu den Web-Blogs. Der eine, der ja da in Bagdad sitzt, da gibt es ja schon Blogs darum, ob er vor Bagdad zu sein, ob er da auch wirklich ist und dann ihre eigenen Streams machen darüber, ob er da nun ist oder nicht.
Ja, das ist richtig, aber da sieht es aber einfach so, es gibt also jemanden, der ist dem mal nachgegangen, der hat die IP-Adressen verfolgt, die er irgendwie hinterlassen hat und auch die Header der E-Mails, die er verschickt hat, haben zwar nicht einen eindeutigen Rückschliss erlaubt, was eigentlich sowieso nicht geht bei Mail, aber auch dem nicht widersprochen. Und aus allem, was er bisher von sich gegeben hat, gibt es eigentlich keinen Grund zu glauben, dass er nicht da ist. Also es gibt keine offensichtliche Sache und er hat vergleichsweise viel Detailkenntnis über bestimmte Sachen gehabt, er hat Sachen beobachtet, berichtet, die dann eben drei, vier, fünf Stunden später über die allgemeinen Kanäle verbreitet wurden, dass eben bestimmte Dinge angegriffen oder nicht angegriffen wurden, was einfach ganz nahe liegt, dass der eben auch tatsächlich vor Ort ist.
Dann wollte ich noch zu Max ergänzend sagen, du hast ja aufgezählt, dass die einzelnen Sondersendungen beim Fernsehen ja immer so sehr interessante verschiedene Titel haben. Die ARD ist schon etwas nachhaltiger geworden. Die meisten titeln da ja Krieg im Irak rein, die sagen Krieg im Nahen Osten. Das ist schon etwas nachhaltiger gefasst für die kommenden Monate. Und bei CNN, die schwächen das natürlich ab. Da heißt es nicht War, sondern Strike Against Iraq.
Ah, okay, da ist sozusagen die aktive Seite gezeigt.
Und NTV als Tochter von CNN, die sagen dann Krieg im Irak. Und da sagen sie natürlich nicht, dass es gegen den Irak geht, sondern es sei ein Krieg im Irak. Da wird dann sozusagen die Seite ein bisschen abgeschwächt, dass es von den Amis oder so ausgehen könnte. Ja, ich wollte noch mal so zwei, zwei, drei Sachen sagen, was mir aufgefallen ist im Vorfeld. Ja, bei Saddam haben sie immer gesagt, wir wissen jetzt nicht, ob nun ein Dudel spricht oder ob es von der Echte ist und aufgezeichnet ist. Diese Rede, die vielleicht nach Beginn der Bombe morgens ausgestrahlt wurde, da sagten sie zwar alle, die ist aufgezeichnet, aber sie waren sich fast alle selbst CNN-sicher, der ist echt, das war der echte Saddam. Das fand ich dann doch schon ziemlich beeindruckend in dem Moment. Ist aber irgendwo auch klar, weil wenn jetzt die Amis da einlaufen, um mit dem Ziel Saddam zu stürzen, muss natürlich das Feindbild auch aufhalten werden. Und am nächsten Tag kam dann natürlich, ja er lebt noch, er lebt noch, aber er ist verletzt. Wir wissen nicht wo er ist, aber wir wissen, wie es ihm geht.
Ja, aber was mir zum Beispiel aufgefallen ist, ich hab das ja auch gehört, und dachte so, okay, er ist also verletzt, also zeigen sie jetzt Saddam wieder. Und mir ist aufgefallen, dass sie Saddam ab dem Zeitpunkt nur noch von der Hüfte, also relativ so vom Brustkasten aufwärts gezeigt haben. Manchmal zeigen sie ein bisschen mehr von ihm auf dem Stuhl oder so, dass du noch so seine Hände siehst. Da war das wirklich nur noch so der obere Teil des Torso, den sie gezeigt haben. War ganz lustig, hab ich immer spekuliert. Sind ihm jetzt die Beine abgefallen bei dem Angriff? Und sie zeigen nur noch den oberen Teil und tun so, als wäre er gesund oder so? Sowas geht einem dann ja durch den Kopf. Oh Mann. Ja, ich fand's ganz lustig, weil diese Nummer mit ist das der echte Saddam. Dann siehst du den Typen und dann haben sie ihn jetzt so abgefilmt, das erste Mal als er aufgetreten ist, er sah total grau aus, der Bart total grau, dann diese wahnsinnsticke Brille und er sah ja aus wie gerade aus dem Schlafzimmer gekommen. Und dann denkst du natürlich, okay, das muss der echte sein, weil der ist so zerknauscht, so würden die den nie zeigen, wenn es ein Double ist. Und dann denkst du, okay, vielleicht sind sie aber so clever, so zu tun, als wäre er total knauschig. Und dann fängst du an, immer wieder hin und her zu denken, bis du irgendwann gar nicht mehr weißt, was du willst.
Und dann einen Tag später haben sie ja die ersten Ergebnisse mit der weißen Fahne gezeigt. Da sagten die Amis natürlich, ja, da haben sich Soldaten ergeben. Im mirakischen Fernsehen kamen dann, das sind doch nur Zivilisten. Und da sieht man halt auch schon, wie das auseinandergeht. Beide legen es zu ihrem Vorteil aus, um natürlich auch entsprechendes Volk dann auf ihre Seite zu zerben. Oder auf ihrer Seite bleiben zu lassen. Und ja, diese Toten, die jetzt Al-Jazeera gezeigt hat, und die ja hier in Deutschland in Teilen gezeigt wurden, und in Amerika wurde das ja gerügt und geächtet, es geht nicht mehr. Und da kamen sie auch mit der Gentrial-Konvention und so an, dass die Amis dagegen Feuer verstoßen haben, interessiert die anscheinend nicht so sehr.
Ja, das ist großartig, wie die Amerikaner binnen 20 Sekunden irgendwie ihre Liebe zur internationalen Gesetzgebung wieder entdeckt haben, wenn es ihnen halt ausnahmsweise mal in Kram passt. Also das war auch dermaßen eine Farce. Da fragt man sich halt auch noch, kann es jetzt überhaupt noch jemanden geben, der das noch glaubt? Glaubwürdigkeit ist also auch wirklich sehr schwierig. Gerade was diese Situation betrifft, wo sich die Iraker ergeben haben. Ich bin dem jetzt im Detail nicht so nachgegangen, aber es gibt da interessante Feststellungen zu der einen Szene, wo so zwei Iraker mit einer weißen Fahne sich ergeben. Und jemand hat sich das mal ein bisschen genauer festgestellt und hat angeschaut und hat einfach festgestellt, dass es bemerkenswert wäre, mit welcher Liebe und Hingabe diese weiße Fahne also auch noch rund abgenäht wäre. Und es wäre also die perfekteste weiße Fahne, die jemals in einem Kriegsgebiet geschwenkt worden wäre. Da kann man sich natürlich so seine Gedanken machen.
Ja, und im Deutschlandfunk hatte ich auch das vorhin, ja, das ist wirklich von der Medien, dass eben diese Gänsekonvention eigentlich hauptsächlich für die Staaten gilt und bei den Medien gar keine große Verpflichtung herrscht. Und dass in den USA es auch lediglich eine Bitte ist, es sei kein großes Verbot, diese Bilder nicht auszustrahlen, sondern von der Regierung nur eine Bitte davon ausgeht, dass diese Bilder nicht gezeigt werden.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja, was irgendwie die Nichtbefolgung einer Bitte für ein amerikanisches Video bedeutet. Danach dürfen sie halt ihre Journalisten nicht mehr einbetten lassen.
Ja, die eingepetteten Reporter sind natürlich auch schön, weil so nahe waren wir noch nie einem Krieg dabei. Und die neuen Techniken machen es uns möglich, noch objektiver und noch detailreicher über den Krieg zu berichten. Das ist ja so diese Anfangsparodie, die da ans Hoch kommt. Aber schön ist auch, dass die embedded reporters immer ihr ganzes Material vor ihrem Kommandeur zeigen müssen und mit ihm absprechen müssen, was denn nun gezeigt werden darf.
Vor allen Dingen, also ich hab neulich eine Szene gesehen, da war so eine junge Dame, die sich offensichtlich sehr angestrengt hat, dass sie dann da im Irak auch berichten darf und die so ungefähr 75 bis 100 Meter vor einem dieser Transporthubschrauber stand. Und da waren die ganzen Truppen schon drin und sie berichtete halt, weil es war Sandsturm und dieser Hubschrauber war an und sie schrie halt immer so I am right now standing in front of a helicopter who is going to start in 50 seconds. Und ich so, ja Schätzchen, das sehen wir. Und in dem Moment kam von hinten der Kommandeur angerannt, stuckste hier so an die Schulter und sagte, komm jetzt, Petrola, wir müssen los. Und dann flog die los und ich dachte so, ey, what the fuck, wofür habt ihr mir das jetzt gezeigt, was ist da embedded, alter, das hätte ich dir von zu Hause erzählen können, weißt du? Und das zeigen die dann und dann tun die so, als wären die echt nah am Geschehen, das sind Details, die kann man sich klemmen. Also bei uns sind die Nachrichten natürlich total detailliert und da wir jetzt 23.30 Uhr haben, müssen wir auch langsam dazu schreiten. Vielen Dank, dass du angerufen hast, Wetterfisch.
Ja, bitteschön und friedliche Tage noch.
Ja, dir auch.
Wenn Fritz in Berlin, dann 102, 6.
In der Nacht erwarten uns immer mehr Wolken, weil Tiefstwerden zwischen 5 und 2 Grad. Morgen bleibt es wolkig. Es gibt auch immer mal wieder Schauer. Die Temperaturen steigen auf 12 bis 16 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Donner. Britische und US-Truppen haben am späten Abend eine umfangreiche Militärkolonne der irakischen Army im Süden von Basra aus der Luft angegriffen. Rund 120 Panzer, Artillerie und Transportwagen seien zuvor von der belagerten Millionenstadt aus aufgebrochen, berichtet ein Journalist, der die britischen Truppen begleitet. Ein britischer Militär in Katar bestätigte, die irakische Kolonne bewege sich in Richtung der alliierten Stellung auf der Halbinsel V. Das militärische Ziel der Offensive sei bislang unklar. Die alliierten Truppen haben am Abend wieder die irakische Stadt Bagdad bombardiert. Reporter berichten von heftigen Explosionen in der Innenstadt. Im Laufe des Tages hatten alliierte Flugzeuge in Bagdad eine irakische Luftabwehrstellung unter Beschuss genommen. Laut dem US-Zentralkommando lag sie mitten in einem Wohngebiet. Zum Zeitpunkt der Bombardierung gab es in Bagdad eine Explosion in einer belebten Geschäftsstraße. Dabei wurden mindestens 15 Menschen getötet. Noch ist allerdings nicht sicher, dass die Explosion und die Bombardierung unmittelbar miteinander im Zusammenhang stehen. Südlich von Bagdad stoßen die alliierten Truppen nach wie vor auf heftigen Widerstand. Für den Nahost-Experten Peter Schollertour ist klar, die Amerikaner haben taktische Fehler gemacht.
Es ist erstaunlich, wie falsch die Psychologie des Landes eingeschätzt worden ist. Die Amerikaner haben wohl auch vergessen, dass die Sanktionen, die über das Land verhängt worden sind, von der Bevölkerung doch sehr schmerzlich empfunden worden sind. Auch wenn sie San Jose nicht mochten oder ihn hassten. Man kann diese langen Nachschublinien, die entstanden sind, ja nur halten, wenn man eine halbwegs freundliche Bevölkerung im Umkreis hat. Das ist eben nicht der Fall.
US-Präsident Bush hat seine Landsleute auf einen längeren Krieg im Irak vorbereitet. Er hielt heute eine Rede auf einem Luftwaffenstützpunkt in Florida. Martin Wagner berichtet.
Meile um Meile kommen wir Bagdad, kommen wir dem Sieg näher. Siegesgewiss und selbstbewusst äußerte sich der amerikanische Präsident. Immer wieder vom Beifall der Soldaten unterbrochen, sagte Bush. Der Weg, den wir beschritten haben, ist nicht einfach. Und möglicherweise lang vor Bagdad stünden dem amerikanischen Militär verzweifelte Einheiten eines zum Untergang verdammten Regimes gegenüber.
Und zum Fußball in der 2.
Bundesliga hat Union Berlin in einem Nahauchholspiel heute gegen Reutlingen 0 zu 0 gespielt. Ja und der Verkehr auf Fritz, wir haben aktuell keine Meldung, deswegen gute Fahrt.
Du willst sie, du kriegst sie. Bestimmen sie mit und wähl deine Lieblingssongs in die 20 plus 1. Die Friseurachats.
Nächsten Sonntag auf der 3. Und auf der 1.
Änderungsvorschläge www.fritz.de 20 plus 1 Jeden Sonntag von 12 bis 14 Uhr. Und im Radio. Um gezielte Desinformation.
Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Wir haben es 20 vor 12 vom Chaos Computer Club im Studio Andreas und Tim. Meine Person Max Formalotky, wunderschönen guten Abend. Es geht heute Abend um Medien und Krieg und Medienmanipulation im Krieg. Thema der 80. Chaos Radio Sendung. Ihr könnt euch beteiligen unter 0331 77 97 110. Vorher gibt es aber noch mal ein kleines Update, wo wir uns so thematisch befinden, damit ihr wisst, was so der Diskussionsstand ist, weil wir schon eine ganze Menge abgehakt haben, kann man so sagen.
In dieser Berichterstattung derzeit gibt es halt so verschiedenste Personen, die besondere Rollen spielen, die es so bisher nicht gab, die es aber auch und die es auch schon mal gab. Das neue Element sind halt diese sogenannten eingebetteten Journalisten, die sozusagen Maulkorb by default haben. Na ja, das haben wir ja eben schon erwähnt. Ich meine, was die sich damit halt eingebrockt haben, ist halt einerseits, dass ihnen eigentlich überhaupt keiner mehr glauben dürfte. Das gilt vielleicht sicherlich nicht für jeden. Auf der anderen Seite sind auch schon einige ordentlich erschossen worden. Also gab es ja diese zwei BBC-Reporter, die irgendwie auch nur so ein bisschen von der Truppe weggekommen sind und dann von irgendwelchen Irakis, die sich wohl offensichtlich ergeben wollten, sozusagen überholt wurden, vorbeifuhren, keine Ahnung, wie das genau gewesen ist. Das weiß man ja auch nicht. Na ja, auf jeden Fall wurden diese Irakis sofort beschossen und die Reporter sind halt dabei mit draufgegangen. Eine komische Rolle, die die spielen.
Ja, eine traurige Rolle in dem Fall. Ich glaube, sie hat so viel Spaß nicht gemacht. Also amüsant, wenn sie das wahrscheinlich nicht gefunden haben. 0-3-1-7-7-9-1-1-0. Wie gesagt, unsere Nummer, wenn ihr euch beteiligen möchtet, eure Meinung zu der Rolle der Medien in diesem Krieg abgeben möchtet. Was denkt ihr? Ist das was, wo ihr euch gut informiert fühlt oder wo ihr sagt, nee, das fällt mir da und da und da? Und vielleicht habt ihr auch noch so ein paar alternative Quellen am Start, weil wir vorhin ja über Weblogs, die alternative Informationsquelle aus dem Internet geredet haben. Wenn ihr da noch was anderes habt, also neben diesen Klassikern, die wir ja im Grunde fast schon genannt haben, wie D von Raid, also Salam Paks, und den Kollegen von warblocks.cc, dann ruft mal an und vielleicht habt ihr ja noch einen coolen Link, den man auch mal ersurfen könnte, damit man das Bild noch etwas erweitert bekommt, was man ja gerne haben möchte. Am Telefon ist der Nils aus Dessau. Hallo, Nils.
Moin, Moin, Jungs. Ich hab nur eine Frage, was anderes.
Das kann ich dir nicht sagen, das hätt ich auch später nicht sagen, weil das alles ein großer Mix ist, der hier läuft und da hab ich keine Ahnung.
Bis dahin muss ich dich schenken. Also jetzt will ich erst mal zum richtigen kommen. Einen Tag vor Klicksbeginn geistete auch bei den öffentlich-rechtlichen Nachrichten im Videotext rum, und zwar, dass der irakische Vizier der Assis geflohen sein soll Richtung Türkei und dabei an der Grenze angeschossen sein soll. Danach war dann, einen Tag später, davon nichts mehr zu hören und nirgends wurde mehr drüber gesprochen.
Naja, wir hatten das Ganze am Anfang der Sendung, das wir so nicht mitbekommen haben. Unsere Vermutung war, dass diese Information eben gezielt gelauncht wurde. Das kam halt über so eine Israel nahestehende Nachrichtenticker-Seite langsam in die Medien rein geträufelt und war halt eine Meldung, die so weit Verbreitung fand, dass am Schluss der Assis es eben für nötig hielt, selber vor die Presse zu treten, um zu zeigen, dass er halt lebt. Damit hat man ihn natürlich auch bewusst sondieren können. Weil in dem Moment, wo er eben da ist, gibt es einfach eine Handvoll von Orte, wo er überhaupt sein konnte, über die die Amis unter Umständen besser Bescheid wissen.
Ja gut, dann war ich glaube gestern oder vorgesehen in der Mitteldeutschen Zeitung hier für Mitteldeutschen Halt eine Meldung, ein kleiner Kommentar über eine Geliebte von Saddam Hussein. Die meinte, ihn mit den Laden des Öfteren gesehen zu haben, stand nicht, woher das kam. Vielleicht von einer Epi. Ja und es wurde dann gleich noch das Bild des bösen Saddams dann wieder geprägt, dass er sich dann bei Sexspielchen irgendwelche vergewaltigte, irgendwelche brutalen Videos angeschaut hat und dass er den Whisky getrunken hat, eine Zigarre geraucht hat und dieses Bild des bösen Saddams halt.
Ja klingt so ein bisschen wie diese Berichterstattung von diesem Mädchen beim letzten Golfkrieg, die irgendwie berichtet hätte, dass die Irakis da die Kinder aus den Brutkästen geklaut haben und später hat sich... Ja, sie war die Tochter des kuwaitischen Botschafters in den USA. Also wie sie überhaupt auf so eine Idee kommen, so eine Person zu nehmen, da fasst man sich ja nun wirklich an den Kopf, aber es war halt alles von vorne bis hinten komplett erstunken und erbogen. Und nicht nur die USA, aber eben auch die USA haben einfach einen langen Track von solchen gefakten Ereignissen, die halt dann eben nicht selten auf zu Kriegsbeginn führen.
Ja und dann möchte ich noch was sagen zum Frankfurt. Vorhin, der meinte, Deutschland soll aus der NATO austreten. Genau falsch. Ich finde, das ist ja gerade so gekommen, weil die USA nicht fest genug in der internationalen Staatengemeinschaft verankert sind, weil die einfach die Macht haben, da rauszukommen. Wie ich finde, die USA soll noch viel mehr auf ihr Recht hochen, einfach die stärkste Macht der Welt zu sein und es einfach sinnvoll nutzen. Da können sich viel, viel mehr Freunde machen und vor allem auch im Nahen Osten punkten. Zum Beispiel war in den Spiegel Anfang des Jahres ein ziemlich interessanter Artikel, wo drin stand, dass der Irak mit politischen Mitteln wahnsinnig schnell zu entwaffnen wäre und zum Beispiel auch Ende der Sanktionen zu wirklich guten Fortschritten führen könnte. Und da müsste man wirklich keinen Krieg führen, das finde ich ziemlich schade. Ich finde es fast noch schlimmer als den Krieg, dass das ganze diplomatisch zugekommen ist. Und die USA hat da eine ziemlich schwierige weltpolitische Lage, die wir kompliziert haben.
Ja, es gibt auch Leute, die sagen, das sei Absicht, dass die USA jetzt sozusagen angefangen haben, nachdem sie überzeugt davon sind, dass sie sowieso die stärksten sind, die neue Weltordnung auf dem Planeten einzuleuten und dass sie sich um viele internationale Beziehungen gar nicht mehr scheren, sondern jetzt einfach ihr eigenes Ding durchziehen und mal ein bisschen die Weltordnung umbauen. Ist sicherlich nur Spekulation, aber eins ist ganz sicher, warum da wirklich Krieg geführt wird, wissen wir das so wirklich genau.
Jo, also zum Schluss will ich noch sagen, ich freue mich auf die nächsten demokratischen ÖLS-Präsidenten.
Was soll das denn sein?
Das kann natürlich noch ein paar Jahrzehnte dauern, will ich sagen.
Ja, Nils, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Na klar, übrigens noch, tolle Sendung, finde ich toll. Und sollte vor allem vielleicht auch am Nachmittag mal laufen, dass da mehr Leute zuhören, weil das ist ziemlich interessant. Also vor allem auch wenn es um die Zensur des Internet und um Informationsfreiheit geht.
Drei Stunden sowas am Nachmittag?
Ja, nein, schwer, aber, na ja.
Da wird der Redaktor was geben.
Wir bemühen uns ja immer mal, so einen Appetizer sozusagen zu machen, der das Ganze mal so im Ansatz erklärt, damit vielleicht der eine oder andere auch hier in den Abend rüber schwappt. Das machen wir ja schon. Ach so, ein Lob, das geht einem ja runter wie Öl, nicht? Euch nicht, oder? Sowas verachtet ihr quasi, ne?
Na ja, ich mein, ich kann ja einfach mal die ganzen Sender übernehmen. Was willst du denn davon?
Das haben wir ja hier getan. Wir sind ja auch live aus Bagdad und das ist natürlich überhaupt keine Propaganda.
Achtung, bei der folgenden Meldung handelt es sich nicht um Propaganda.
Wir hören nämlich das Chaosradio auf RETZ und wir haben es zwölf Minuten vor zwölf, d.h. wir haben noch eine gute Stunde Zeit zu quatschen. Andreas, Tim und Max sind hier und ihr könnt anrufen unter 033 77 97 110. Thematisch wollen wir denn noch mal einen Schritt weitergehen?
Ja, mir ist bloß gerade was aufgefallen, du hattest andere Quellen erwähnt, es gibt Aljazeera ja auch im Internet zum Klicken, nicht nur im Fernsehen und angeblich gibt es seit heute auch ein englisches Aljazeera, das war vor 3-4 Tagen noch arabisch und ich versuche schon den ganzen Tag mir das mal anzugucken und ich kann den Webserver nicht mehr erreichen und das ist natürlich die Frage, warum sind die das nicht gewöhnt, dass so viele Leute drauf rumklicken oder fährt da jemand einen gezielten Angriff, wer weiß es. Also auch das ist Bestandteil.
Das ist bereits berichtet worden, dass es gezielte Angriffe gegeben hat, es gibt also seit gestern irgendwie massive DOS-Attacken, also Denial of Service-Attacken, sprich Angriffe über das Netz, die verhindern, dass ein Server seine Dienste, die er normalerweise anbietet, auch weiter anbietet. Und ganz offensichtlich gibt es da gerade Kräfte, die halt das Netz benutzen. Es ist ja auch offizielle Doktrin der USA, dass sie halt alles nutzen werden, um irgendwie den Feind auf allen Ebenen zu schlagen. Da gehört die elektronische Kriegsführung auf jeden Fall mit dazu. Ist natürlich auch wunderbar doppelzüngig, wie die da halt an Start gehen. Also auf der einen Seite werden halt die armen Hacker irgendwie dafür in den Kerker geworfen, wenn sie irgendwie dumme Verschlüsselungssysteme auseinanderklamm büsern, wie das jetzt mehrfach passiert ist. Und niemand darf sozusagen aber auch nur ein Programm entwickeln, mit dem man vielleicht unter Umständen theoretisch einmal so etwas tun kann. Aber auf der anderen Seite ist es eben offizielle Staatsräson, genau dieses eben zu tun mit anderen Staaten. Ist das Punkt IQ, die Top-Level Domain vom Irak? Ja. Punkt IQ war dann auch irgendwie weg so vor ein paar Monaten. Das hat irgendwie nicht mehr funktioniert. Und wenn man halt geguckt hat, wer für Punkt IQ zuständig ist, dann war das halt eine Firma in Texas. Also die Kontrolle, die die USA auch über das Internet, gerade in diesem Domain-Namespace ausübt, ist halt in den Stellen sehr kritisch. Und sie haben halt einfach die Möglichkeit, Zugänge über das Internet einfach effektiv zu sperren. Ich denke, das ist auch genau das, was wir jetzt gerade sehen. Also ich hab hier irgendwie www.aljazira.net, Server not found. Da hab ich vor zwei Tagen noch irgendwie schnell Seiten geliefert bekommen. Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, irgendwie schnell genug ist, Server aufzustellen. Das ist wirklich ein Drama.
Vom Buchstabieren her, nur das wird irgendwie auf eine englische Schreibweise.
www.aljazira.net ist die offizielle Homepage. Die war, wie gesagt, bis vor kurzem allein in Arabisch und sei jetzt auch Englisch. Und seitdem sie das angekündigt haben, hab ich diese Webseite noch nicht gesehen. Und ich hab auch den Eindruck, das ist ein Thema, mit dem wir uns in den nächsten Tagen noch etwas beschäftigen werden müssen.
Ja, mich würde es allerdings auch mal interessieren, was die so an Berichterstattung treiben, weil mir der Zugang zu solchen DX-Geschichten, also zu so Kisten über Satellit, eigentlich eher verwehrt ist. Also da hab ich die Zugangsmöglichkeiten nicht. Aber zum Beispiel eine Frage, die auch aufkam, wo ich, glaub ich, vor zwei Tagen in den Tagesthemenbericht darüber gesehen habe, war, dass ja immer berichtet wird, auch von USA, dass diese Stadt wasserversorgungstechnisch, stromversorgungstechnisch, also Bugdart, eigentlich schon wirklich ins Mittelalter zurückgebombt worden ist. Dass da im Grunde überhaupt nichts mehr funktioniert. Und dann werden aber auf einmal Bilder gezeigt, wie Studenten irgendwo in der Uni sitzen und im Internet surfen und sich da eben vergnügen. Wo man sich fragt, wie schaffen die das? Ist ja auch genau der Punkt, weswegen Raeed, dieser Kollege, der da dieses Weblog veröffentlicht, wie der überhaupt die Möglichkeit hat, da noch rauszukommen, wenn die versuchen, diese ganze Kommunikation abzubrechen. Weil von USA-Seite ist das ja da wahrscheinlich auch der Fall.
Na ja, die zivile Infrastruktur haben sie ja bewusst verschont. Also auch die Fernseh-Ausstrahlung und so weiter haben sie am Leben gelassen. Wahrscheinlich, weil sie ja sozusagen ihren Claim, dass sie nur militärische Ziele angreifen, sozusagen auch damit dokumentiert sehen wollen. Weil sie ja auch sehen, dass noch relativ viel berichtet wird. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, dass jetzt der Irak ein vollständig unterentwickeltes Land ist. So, ja, das ist ja nicht Afghanistan, wo es irgendwie nicht einen Computer gibt, sondern das ist, na, ich will jetzt nicht mit dem Spruch die Wiege der Zivilisation ankommen, aber die sind nicht jetzt irgendwie so komplett hinter dem Mond. Das ist ein Land wie jedes andere auch. Da ist zwar auch ein bisschen wärmer, da gibt es Sandstürme, aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass sie keine Computer haben.
Nee, das nicht, das war ja auch gar nicht die, also das war ja im Grunde nicht die Aussage, sondern einfach, dass die USA immer wieder behaupten, sie hätten das alles schon abgestellt, merkwürdigerweise. Also ich verstehe nicht, warum die das überhaupt behaupten.
Dass sie was abgestellt haben, das Internet?
Naja, dass sie eben halt diese ganzen infrastrukturellen Geschichten schon erledigt hätten und dass dann immer wieder die Meldung kommt, es gibt da keinen Strom wegen des Stroms, der da fehlt, gibt es kein Wasser mehr und so weiter. Also so dieser Totalausfall, der wird immer wieder propagiert und dann siehst du, da würde die da mit ihren Autos rumfahren und holen die sich da ihr Obst und so weiter und so fort. Zum Beispiel dieser Kollege Raeed, der schreibt ja ganz interessante Sachen, die man sonst wirklich nirgendwo liest, darüber, was er so im Everyday Life einfach macht. Sowas kriegt man ja nirgendwo zu fassen bei einem Tagesthema oder so. Der hat dann zum Beispiel berichtet, das hatten wir heute Morgen auch bei den Radio-Fritzen am Morgen drin, dass er sagt, ja, ich hab mir irgendwie Zucchinis gekauft und diese kosten 1000 Dinar und nicht mehr 250, ist teurer geworden. Merkwürdigerweise ist heute mal wieder die Müllabfuhr vorbeigekommen und so. Solche Kleinigkeiten, die eben genau das ausmachen, was das bedeutet, diese Angst und was für Hoffnungen und so. Das ist eben halt das, was die Medien überhaupt nicht vermitteln können, habe ich so das Gefühl momentan.
Ja, da wird ja auch teilweise sehr interessant versucht zu manipulieren. So mit dem irgendwie Ja, wir sind jetzt hier noch im Kämpfen, aber die humanitären Hilfen, die haben wir jetzt vorbereitet. Das geht dann alles bald los. So irgendwie, dass es so rüberkommt, als würden sie denen ja eigentlich helfen wollen und dass sie aber vorher die Infrastruktur kaputtgebombt haben, die dann wieder aufgebaut wird. Das kommt dann nicht so bei rüber.
Am Telefon ist der Hartwin, Name Hartwin. Deinen Beitrag zum Thema Medien, Medienmanipulationen im Irak?
Ja, der kommt ein bisschen von, ein bisschen weit weg. Der ist aus den Philippinen, also ein Bekannter von mir, ist dort ausgewandert zu seiner Frau. Und der hatte, letzten Freitag hatte er in Manila zu tun, da musste er sich seinen Stempel abholen, damit er dort auch bleiben darf. Und hatte dann eine Mail dazu geschrieben und da war ein schöner Absatz drin, den ich ganz gerne mal zum Besten geben möchte. Da ging es um Medienmanipulation und zwar im Speziellen. Fängt an, wir nahmen einen Taxi zur Einladungsbehörde und erfuhren die letzten Irak-Krieg-Neuigkeiten. Zum Beispiel, dass Deutschland und Frankreich mittlerweile fest auf Seiten der Amerikaner stehen. Beide, mein Schwager und der Taxifahrer, hatten das aus Fernsehen und Presse rausgehört bzw. rausgelesen. Bei dem niedrigen Einkommen hier können die US-Spezialabteilungen zur internationalen Meinungsmacher mit wenig Kleingeld offensichtlich sehr effektiv gefälschte Nachrichten im Verkehr bringen. Das war's so. Sagt mir aus, dass die aus irgendeinem Grund sich scheinbar mental ein runterholen müssen oder sowas. Und in der ganzen Welt klarmachen, zumindest der dritten Welt klarmachen wollen, dass also irgendwie dann wohl doch die die anderen alle mitmachen und alle mithelfen. Ich weiß nicht, was es bringen soll und wie sie es auflösen wollen, falls denn die Deutschen tatsächlich der Meinung sind, ihre Spürpanzer abzuziehen und ihre Erwächsmannschaften. Aber möglicherweise kommt sowas ja dann noch nicht dort an.
Das war in den Philippinen?
Ja, die Philippinen. Ein ziemlich US-amerikanisch angehauchtes Etwas. Also Ansprache war dort mal irgendwie Englisch und ist dann jetzt wohl Philippiner oder sowas. Aber das Gesetz, das das festlegte, wurde auch in Englisch gehalten. Also die wurden halt doll befreit von den Amis.
Die Amis haben gerade jüngst ihre Truppen verstärkt und wollen ja unter anderem auch gegen die... Wie heißt die noch? Gleich da die Vögel?
Ja, das sind da die Einwäschermassen.
Wie soll man sich das alles merken? Diese Terroristengruppe in den Philippinen, die die Deutschen da einführt haben.
Bin ich gerade aber auch nicht drauf.
Das ist irgendwo auf im Süden der Philippinen. Also er meinte, irgendwie wäre das wie Deutschland und Jugoslawien nur mit dem Ozean dazwischen. Also, das ist zwar noch Philippinen, aber so richtig, naja, egal.
Abu Sayyaf heißt die Gruppe jetzt, hab ich's wieder. Ja, ich meine, das ist natürlich eine Meldung, die dann sozusagen den Philippinos das Gefühl geben kann, alle stehen hinter den USA, so warum tun wir das nicht auch, wenn sogar schon die Deutschen dabei sind.
Das Wesentliche dabei ist einfach nur die Tatsache, dass man also in dritte Weltländern tatsächlich wunderbar die Presse manipulieren kann. Man muss dazu sagen, dass dort auf den Philippinen es keinem Ausländer erlaubt ist, ein Presseorgan zu besitzen. Das heißt also, einen zum Beispiel aus Deutschland dort hineingewanderten Mensch durfte zum Bedürfte keinen Verlag haben. Auch keinen Zeitstoffen oder Buchverlag oder ähnliches. Bedeutet also, dass diese dortigen Verlage echt von außen manipuliert werden müssen oder zumindest irgendwie bearbeitet werden müssen. Und wenn es die Journalisten sind, die entsprechend bestochen werden.
Ja, das geben die Amerikaner sogar offen zu, dass es da ein Programm gibt, um Journalisten günstig zu stimmen. Und da gibt es auch Mittel für die offiziell bewilligt wurden. Also das verheimlichen die ja nicht mal.
Ja gut, also wie gesagt, das war jetzt einfach mal nur der Hinweis, es funktioniert. Es funktioniert sehr gut sogar. Also in der Richtung.
Okay, danke Hartwin.
Das war eigentlich alles. Schön, danke.
Habt ihr, weil wir vorhin drauf gekommen waren, sind wir ja nicht näher darauf eingegangen, was das Repräsentiertsein arabischer Beurteilung des Ganzen auch bei uns in den Medien angeht. Was habt ihr eigentlich so gesehen, was sowas anbelangt? Was für eine Art von Berichterstattung, die dann zumindest das mal so ansatzweise gesagt hätte, habt ihr denn so mitgekriegt?
Es gab im Vorfeld, im Januar schon, eine etwas längere Dokumentation. Ich glaube, das war relativ aktuell. Ich glaube, von dem Peter Sholatur, der ja so ein Arabien-Expert ist, der irgendwie über zahlreiche Länder da auch in dem Umfeld berichtet hat, da ging es mehr noch um den Afghanistan-Konflikt. Aber er hat halt aus Usbekistan und anderen Afghanistan umgebenden Ländern, also im Prinzip den gesamten zentralasiatischen Raum berichtet und die Hintergründe geschildert, auch wie die zu den Amerikanern stehen und natürlich auch zu den Russen. Also die ganzen Konflikte, ich will das jetzt im Detail gar nicht so wiedergeben. Und, oh guck mal, da ist gerade Apple-Werbung auf CNN.
Jo, der Apple ist abgelenkt.
Wir wollen uns doch nicht ablenken lassen. Aber wir können mal reinhören.
Oh, ich hab mich getäuscht.
Das ist manipuliert worden, Tim.
Ja, ich dachte die Tastatur leuchtet gleich auf. Ja, ich bin manipuliert worden. Naja, also das war schon etwas, was da war. Dann gab es noch so eine andere Dokumentation, die vor allem den Golfkrieg halt nochmal Revue passieren lässt. Ich meine, was auch immer wieder interessant ist, es gibt einfach auch bestimmte Zahlen, die einfach nicht genannt werden. Wie viele Leute sind eigentlich beim letzten Golfkrieg umgekommen? Wie viele Iraker sind dabei umgekommen? 200, 250.000 in der Größenordnung. Was für eine Zahl. Dazu sind, glaube ich, 811 alliierte Truppen gestorben. Einer zu 2.000, so ist ungefähr das Verhältnis.
Ja, es ist auch bemerkenswert, dass im Prinzip zu Zeiten der Sanktionen allein durch die Sanktionen im Irak jeden Monat mehr Leute gestorben sind, als beim Terroranschlag vom 11. September umgekommen sind. 5.000 sind das jeden Monat. Da fragt man sich auch ein bisschen, wo die Verhältnisse sind, ob das jetzt so schlimm das war. Also erstens das als Ausrede zu benutzen und dann irgendwie gleich die 20- 30- 40- 50-fache Menge Leuten umzubringen und dann noch für sich in Anspruch zu nehmen, auf der moralisch richtigen Seite zu stehen, finde ich außerordentlich zweifelhaft. Wird mir auch immer ganz übel, wenn ich den Busch reden sehe.
Also mir ist zum Beispiel aufgefallen, dass mal abgesehen von sowas wie diesen Features, könnte man ja fast sagen, von Peter Stolartour, dieses Ding war relativ lang, das kam, glaube ich, auf Phönix oder XXP oder sowas. Das war, glaube ich, eine Stunde oder anderthalb. Das war ein richtiger Brocken, der auch sehr, sehr spannend war. Was aber so vorneweg gesendet wurde, ist mir aufgefallen, dass dann erst mal, als diese Berichterstattung angefangen hat, eigentlich ein sehr, sehr großer Schwerpunkt gelegt wurde auf, was passiert in Deutschland, was passiert in Amerika, was passiert in England. So, die Resonanz der großen Partner sozusagen und uns, weil wir uns eben für unser Land interessieren. Und ab dem Zeitpunkt, wo es dann in Cairo langsam losging oder auch in anderen arabischen Ländern, da hat man dann gemerkt, okay, jetzt nehmen sie sich langsam die Experten ran und mit diesen Experten erörtern sie jetzt, ob das Ganze die arabische Welt möglicherweise destabilisieren könnte. Aber das war Tatsache erst, das war ja so Samstag oder so war das. Da haben die das erste Mal in der Richtung überhaupt irgendwas gemacht, weil solange war der Krieg irgendwie aktuell und da passiert jetzt gerade was, da müssen wir noch nicht über die Auswirkungen sprechen. So kam einem das vor. Ganz merkwürdig.
Ja, Experten, das ist überhaupt ein tolles Thema. Also jeder Fernsehsender hat ja einen. So, die unterhalten sich da auch immer wieder eben auch über diese ganzen Nicht-Informationen. Und vor allem diese Experten werden dann eigentlich auch immer wieder halt irgendwelche Ex-Generäle, Leute, die sie halt vor X Jahren schon irgendwie aus der Bundeswehr rausgeschmissen haben, Politikwissenschaftler, die sonst irgendwie keiner mehr aus ihren Büros rausgeholt hätte. Die werden halt jetzt alle wieder rausgekramt. Und alles, was halt in irgendeiner Form auftaucht, wird dann halt zur Tode analysiert. Im Prinzip kommt dabei halt auch nichts raus, weil es sich einfach immer nur um das Deuten von vollkommen, von Sachen, die man nicht einschätzen kann, handelt, weil es einfach keine Grundlage dafür gibt. Also die ganze Berichterstattung mangelt einfach die Grundlage der Informationen. Man merkt es auch nach den ersten drei Tagen, wo ja im Prinzip 24 Stunden Berichterstattung war, es schwächt jetzt schon ab. Ich wundere mich. Also ich hatte gezählt in der ersten Nacht, als der Krieg losging. Ich hab irgendwie auf meinem Kabel, was war das? Ich glaube, ich hab 34 Sender. Und von diesen 34 Sendern haben, glaube ich, 24 Krieg gebracht. Und dann war halt noch ein bisschen Homeshopping und ein bisschen Titten wackeln. Und nach drei Tagen hat sich das halt geändert. Jetzt ist es irgendwie schon so, dass im Wesentlichen die deutschen Sender auch so ihr Programm durchziehen. Dann haben wir dann auch mal wieder die Spielfilme gezeigt. Dann blätter ich so ein bisschen durch die Programmzeitschrift, was ich selten tue. Und so an dem letzten Wochenende, also wenn man sich anschaut, was da alles so lief, Kriegsfilme und Armee-Einsatz. Also nur Horror und Action und Kriegsfilme.
Aber was ich ja löblich fand, ich finde Vox ja normalerweise nicht toll, aber Vox hat diese ganzen Dinger gebracht, weil wir natürlich in Deutschland sind, und die wissen, die Stimmung ist hier so. Dave, das ist dieser Film mit, wie heißt er? Auf jeden Fall spielt Sigourney Weaver, spielt irgendwie die Frau des Präsidenten, und er spielt das Präsidentendubel. Und da geht es halt mal um einen netten Präsidenten, was passieren würde, wenn die dumme Sau durch einen netten Typen aus dem Volke ersetzt werden würde. Und am Ende, nachdem der vorbei war, haben sie direkt King Ralph geteased, was auch der Herrscher wird ersetzt Film ist. Und auch, das ist mal der nette Herrscher. Und da haben sie so einen Schwerpunkt drauf gesetzt. Fand ich ganz lustig. Das kontra natürlich Tausende von Kriegsfilmen. Die Brücke von Arnheim 1 bis 17 und wie sie alle heißen.
Tina meint Kevin Klein.
Richtig. Apropos, das wollte ich vorhin schon fragen. Da du dich da in so einem Chat bewegst, wie ist der denn greifbar für alle, die sich da auch einloggen möchten?
Das ist hier der interne Chat, der uns mit Informationen versorgt. Der ist nicht so richtig greifbar. Vorhin waren wir noch im Chat auf kiffer.de, als wir hier nur übers Web rausgekommen sind.
Du bist in unserem Chat?
Ja.
Wie hast du denn das gemacht?
Na, ich habe mich hier rausgeschmuggelt und mich auf meinem Host eingeloggt und von da...
Wie hast du dich denn... Ich will auch...
Geil, Tim stellt die Fragen, die ich auch immer stelle.
Ja, wir sind hier sozusagen von einer Portsperre bedroht. Wir kommen hier nicht so aus, wie wir gerne wollen. Wir sind ja hier im Kriegsgebiet und das ist alles ein bisschen schwierig. Und ich muss jetzt mal kurz durken, weil da kommt wieder eine Tomahawk.
Das ist eigentlich jetzt gar nicht so gemeint, wie es sich anhört, aber 5 nach 12 hört sich ja schon ziemlich brisant an. Das heißt, wir haben noch eine knappe Stunde Zeit zu reden. Medien und Medienmanipulation, die Thema des der achtenzigsten Chaos-Radiosendungen.
Die Gelegenheit werde ich gleich nutzen, darauf hinzuweisen, ihr könnt uns Feedback schicken an 80 at chaosradio.ccc.de und weitere Informationen findet ihr wie immer auf unserer Homepage unter chaosradio.ccc.de oder auch www.ccc.de.
Genau, und wo wir gerade bei Sekundärinformationen sind, möchte ich hier auch nochmal an unsere Zielgruppe gerichtet ein bisschen Ankündigungen leisten. Es gibt einige Veranstaltungen, die anstehen beim CCC. Wer Lust hat, daran teilzunehmen. Im Ostern gibt es in Hamburg das Easter Hack, was so ein etwas gemütlicheres Miniature-Congress-Treffen ist, was über ein paar Tage geht. Das ist eigentlich wieder vier Tage oder sind es diesmal nur drei Tage? Ich hab jetzt gar nicht geschaut. Wie auch immer, das findet sich alles auf www.ccc.de. Und im Sommer dann werden wir das Chaos Communication Camp veranstalten. Das geht dann über vier Tage. Das ist Hackerparty im Freien.
Mit Lockpicking-Unterwasser-Contest wahrscheinlich wieder, oder? Das sind die Sachen, die ich mir immer merke, das ist so krass.
Ja, das war zumindest angedroht. Mal schauen, ob das was wird. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall alles in Vorbereitung. Informationen dazu jetzt schon spärlich unter www.ccc.de. Demnächst dort mehr. Dort gibt es auch eine Mailing-Liste, auf die man sich einschreiben kann und schon fleißig Fragen fragen kann. Und das Ganze wird vom 7. bis zum 10. August stattfinden.
Wo wir vorhin bei Experten-Dissen waren, ich finde ja den schlimmsten Experten, also wirklich die Pappnase vor dem Herrn. Ich weiß gar nicht, woher der seine Kompetenz zieht. Haben sie beim ZDF gezeigt. Und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den schon mal gesehen habt, Ben Works.
Dieser Amerikaner, der irgendwie alles...
So ein Typ, der so eine Fliege anhat und so aussieht, als würde er gerade von einer Dinnerparty kommen. Und dann sagen die immer so, wir schalten jetzt nach Washington, glaube ich, wenn ich mich nicht ganz täusche, zu Nenene Henene und unserem Experten Ben Works. Und dann sagt irgendwie der total hilflose Journalist zu Ben Works, ja, was ist denn gerade los? Und dann macht Ben Works irgendwie auf so einer komischen Tafel rum und zeigt so, wo seiner Meinung nach die Panzerdivisionen stehen und hat irgendwie, als die gerade erst in den Irak einmarschiert waren, gesagt, ja, die stehen 40 Kilometer vor Bagdad. Solche Sachen. Einfach mal so hingehustet. Warum? Wieso? Wo hat der das her? Warum glaubt der, dass das so ist? Wie viele Divisionen und was soll das sein? Nö. Einfach nur mal so ein Bit of Information, bei der keiner weiß, wo das eigentlich herkommt. Ben Works, die Fliege, wenn ich die noch mal sehe, die der um den Hals hat, da werd ich fruchtig. Ihr könnt anrufen, Lola317797110. Wo seid ihr denn vielleicht fruchtig geworden? Bei welcher Art von Informationen? Wir haben jetzt auch mal ein bisschen mehr Platz hier in der Chaosradio Lounge. Also ihr könnt durchaus die Chance haben, dann auch mal durchzukommen. Ich weiß, hier wird viel gequatscht und auch lang, weil die Theoreme ja nicht so die kürzesten sind. Aber am Telefon ist der Opi, hallo.
Ja, nabend ihr Chaoten. Ja, also die Sache mit den Experten, bevor ich jetzt auf meine beiden Punkte komme, das ist auch eine ganz fürchterliche. Also ich finde es auch ganz schlimm. Ich beschäftige mich schon ziemlich lang mit Medienjournalismus und dieses Expertentum ist wirklich zum Kotzen. Da hat die Radikampagne hier in Berlin auch einen schönen Text zu geschrieben. Also wer sich dafür interessiert, muss ja mal auf radikampagne.de klicken. Da steht über die Sache des Experten und so weiter. Was ich eigentlich erzählen wollte, ist, es gibt ja jeden Tag Pressekonferenzen im Central Command, also dem Hauptquartier der Streitkräfte da im Golf. Und da gibt es ja immer so einen Saal voller Journalisten, die dann diesem Pressesprecher, diesem General, Landse wieder Fragen stellen dürfen. Und da stehen dann halt immer irgendwelche Leute auf. Und heute haben sie halt vermehrt danach gefragt, dass angeblich Irakis in US oder in britischen Militäruniformen als Selbstmordattentäter durch die Wüste rennen. Das ist nirgendswo anders aufgetaucht. Aber die Fragen kamen irgendwie von 15 verschiedenen Journalisten oder 12. Genau hab ich nicht gezählt. Und das finde ich doch schon ganz schön interessant, wie man so versucht, so ein Thema zu platzieren, was dann zum Glück von BBC und auch selbst von CNN und so nicht aufgegriffen wird. Aber das probieren die anscheinend jeden Tag.
Das war so eine Kiste, womit die dann wahrscheinlich eine Woche später erklären wollten, warum dieser eine US-Soldat da selber eine Granate in das Zelt von seinen Kumpels geworfen hat oder so.
Ja, also weiß man's. Und die andere Sache, die ich noch kurz erzählen wollte, ist ganz viele Experten oder Medienleute, zum Beispiel der Novotny, der ehemalige WDR-Intendant und jetzige Medienratsmitglied hier in Berlin-Warnburg, der hat sich so tierisch darüber aufgeregt, dass dieses ganze Berichterstattungsding im Fernsehen so an Videospiele und Videospiel-Ästhetik so erinnert. Das finde ich immer ganz interessant, wenn dann so 60-jährige Leute irgendwie erzählen, wie ihrer Meinung nach Videospiele auszusehen haben. Ich finde das Problem, es sind nicht so die Pixelbilder von den Embedded Journalists aus den Panzern, die da live oder quasi live abgelinkt werden und da zum Satelliten hochschalten. Ich finde auch die Nachtaufnahmen nicht so problematisch, sondern was ich viel schlimmer finde, sind diese animierten Karten und diese animierten Modelle, gerade bei CNN. Die stellen ja dann immer, wenn jetzt irgendeine Division vorgestellt wird, stellen die ja dann gerade die Waffen da auf dem animierten Screen, wo sich dann so ein graues 3D-Modell von dem Flugzeug, dem Panzer oder dem Schiff oder der Tomahawk-Missil, wie auch immer. Dieser Trailer, ne? Der Trailer sieht ja schon aus wie Command & Conquer oder so. Sondern richtig, nein, in der Live-Übertragung, wenn sie halt den Corrospenden an der Strippe haben, schalten sie mal kurz auf so einen Computerschirm, der sie dann quasi direkt auf den Bildschirm holen. Und da machen sie dann so eine Detailliste, wie viel Reichweite das hat, wie viel Munition, wann es eingesetzt wurde. Und dann dreht sich halt so ein animiertes Modell, so ein graues Modell. Oder auf den Landkarten fahren dann echte Panzer hin und her, oder Hubschrauber, wo sich dann der Rotor dreht. Bei den Panzern bewegt sich so der Turm die ganze Zeit von Reich nach links.
Ja, ja, eben gerade lief auf CNN so ein schöner Zoom direkt in Irak runter auf ein Flughafen oder ein Flugfeld mit irgendwie, und hier steht das Abwehrgeschütz, und hier kommt irgendwie der Unterstand, und da ist das Flugzeug drin und tralala. Also klar.
Das finde ich...
Aber ich meine, tatsächlich ist es ja auch so. Ich meine, US-Soldaten, also nicht nur US-Soldaten, aber vor allem US-Soldaten werden auch an videospielartigen Systemen ausgebildet. Es gibt Simulatoren für den Kriegseinsatz. Und ich hab da nicht jetzt zu viel Detailkenntnis, aber es ist offensichtlich, dass sie eben ausgebuffte Kommunikationssysteme haben, zumindest die so genannten Special Forces, in ihren Helmen mit eingebaut haben. Funk untereinander, eben auch Datenaustausch, Positionsaustausch.
Also ich denke, auch bei diesen verangestellten Drohnen wird der Unterschied zwischen der Simulation in einem realen Einsatz fast gar nicht mehr wahrnehmbar sein. Also das sind einfach dieselbe Software, dieselben Kontrollen, die da angezeigt wird. Das ist ein Videospiel. Die drücken da auf den Knopf und da hinten macht's bumm. Und dummerweise, wo's bumm macht, sind halt Leute, die dabei sterben. Hm, ja, sieht man halt nicht, wenn man so weit weg sitzt.
Ja, spart man sich auf die Militärpsychologen dann nach dem Krieg. Also, wenn das nur noch ein Computerspiel ist, kann man ja einfach neu starten.
Gut, aber irgendwie wedelt da ja der Schwanz noch ein bisschen mit dem Hund, weil Tatsache ist ja, dass diese Videospiele sich auch mal an irgendwas orientiert haben. Ist ja nicht so, als wären die Videospiele so, poof, einfach so da gewesen und hätten auf einmal diese Ästhetik gehabt, die es vorher nie gegeben hätte und danach hätte sich der Krieg orientiert. Die haben sich ja schon nach dem orientiert, was der Krieg immer schon gemacht hat.
Deshalb haben nämlich diese ganzen 50-jährigen Medien-Experten Unrecht, wenn sie sagen, dass die Live-Übertragung halt aussieht wie ein Videospiel. Das finde ich eben nicht, sondern ich finde, es halt schon eine Chance ist, jetzt bei diesem dritten Golfkrieg oder zweiten Irakkrieg oder wie man das immer nummeriert, dass man da halt schon mal Bilder sieht, dass es halt wirklich ein dreckiger Krieg ist. Und ich glaube, so wenig Möglichkeiten, die Embedded Journalists in den Konvois, in den Militär-Truppen selbst haben. Aber sie haben ja schon für einen Stimmungsumschwung gesorgt, indem sie halt dann doch gesagt haben, wir kämpfen hier gerade, wir stehen hier gerade vor Basra. Und dann haben sie einen Schwenk gemacht auf Soldaten, die da irgendwelche Kurzstreckenraketen in so ein Wasserwerk gefeuert haben, wo noch ein paar irakische Soldaten waren. Und Stunden vorher hat dann halt irgendeinen Außenminister oder irgendeinen Ministerpräsident gesagt, wir haben Basra schon eingenommen und hinter uns gelassen. Da haben sie sich dann doch schon ins Knie geschossen, die lieben US-Militärs mit ihren Embedded Journalists.
Die Frage ist, wenn es live gesendet wird, wie häufig wird es dann wiederholt? Ich glaube, die Berichterstattung lebt auch teilweise von der Wiederholung von Bildern. Übrigens auch bei diesen Live-Camps, wo sie dann auch die sogenannten Live-Camps immer wieder cyklen lassen. Das ist ja mal wieder das gleiche Auto, was immer wieder im Kreis fährt.
Da gibt es noch ein viel besseres Bild. Und zwar gibt es ja immer wieder Bilder von Verletzten. Und es gibt so einen verletzten Jungen, ich schätze mal 12 Jahre alt, einen irakischen Jungen, der halt in so einem Krankenbett sitzt. Er hat so ein violettfarbenes T-Shirt mit so einem großen, kreisförmigen Blutflag auf der Brust, auf dem T-Shirt drauf. Das scheint nicht von ihm zu sein, sondern da wird da wahrscheinlich einfach irgendwo Blut abgekriegt haben. Und das senden sie jetzt mittlerweile schon, das haben sie gesendet nach den ersten Bombenangriffen. Da habe ich es dann noch gedacht, dass es halt aus Bagdad ist. Mittlerweile wird es halt auch bei Bildern verwendet, die dann halt aus irgendwelchen Kleinstädten bei Basra oder wo sie sonst wo noch auf erbitterten Widerstand gestoßen sind, wird das dann mittlerweile da auch noch gesendet als sozusagen Originalbild der dortigen Verletzten. Aber so viele Jungs mit einem violetten T-Shirt, mit einem kreisförmigen Blutflag kann es im Irak glaube ich nicht geben. Und von daher zeigt es dann auch wieder so ein bisschen die Armut der hiesigen Fernsehsender oder so. Einfach dann auch mal, sie sagen es ja bei den Korrespondenten, geben sich ja die ganze Zeit zu, dass sie nichts wissen. Aber dass sie dann halt diese Bilder immer wieder aus dem Archiv rausholen, das finde ich dann schon ein bisschen traurig. Aber ich kann mir auch vorstellen, wo das herkommt. Und zwar sind ja diese ganzen Sachen mittlerweile auf einem Video-Server gespeichert. Beispielsweise im Hauptstadtstudio der ARD, haben die ja kaum noch Bänder. Und dann, wenn die die Datei nicht ordentlich benennen, da steht halt nur noch irakisches Kind verletzt im Krankenhaus und nicht mal mehr der Ort und das Datum. Das passt dann halt nicht mehr in die Dateibeschreibung rein oder so. Ich glaube, da fehlt dann einfach an genug Meta-Information.
Eine Vermutung von dir.
Na ja, wie gesagt, ich interessiere mich so ein bisschen dafür und ich kenne halt die Systeme, die im Einsatz sind. Und da kann man halt nicht so viel reinschreiben. Das ist so wie aus guten alten DOS-Zeiten, nur 255 Zeichen oder so. Da kann man halt nicht irgendwie große Kommentare reinschreiben.
Das Problem ist aber auch, dass das eine psychologische Folge hat, weil die ganze Sache immer so runtergekocht wird. Das ist ja auch das, leider die Aufgabe der Medien so ein bisschen ist, in verträgliche Häppchen zu verpacken und man sowieso ja so in die 2 Minuten 30 Gesellschaft unterwegs ist. Da kriege ich mein Essen in 2 Minuten 30, da kriege ich meine Infos in 2 Minuten 30 und so weiter und so fort. Und das dann einfach, dass austauschbar wird. Du siehst da eben halt das irakische Kind im Krankenhaus. Man braucht gar nicht mehr das neue irakische Kind im Krankenhaus zu sehen, weil es könnte ungefähr so ausgesehen haben. Und dann könnte es immer so ausgesehen haben. Und irgendwann lebst du nur noch von Versatzstücken, bist natürlich total abgestumpft, weil du weißt, ah ja, ich erinnere mich, irakisches Kind im Krankenhaus. Ja, ja, schon zweimal gesehen, kenne ich die Videoaufnahme. Deswegen, wenn du mal merkst, wie schnell ist dieser Krieg eigentlich für die normale Bevölkerung schon uninteressant geworden. Das Ding ist jetzt gerade mal eine Woche her, dass es die heiße Phase ist, und es interessiert sich im Grunde schon keine Sau mehr dafür. Wir alle sagen nur noch, hoffentlich ist die Sache bald vorbei.
Worauf beziehst du dich jetzt dabei, bei dieser Einschätzung?
Einfach nur daran, wie viel Präsenz dem Ganzen in den Medien jetzt noch zugestanden wird. Wenn du zum Beispiel mal denkst, 11. September war richtig shocking. Das ist richtig fett gelaufen. Da wurde sehr, sehr lange spekuliert. Das ist uns richtig auf den Brustkorb gegangen. Da haben alle mal gesagt, oh man, wir können noch keine Witze machen. Das ist noch zu hart. Das vertragen die Leute noch nicht. Medienleute sind ja ganz schlimm, Medienleute sind ja fies. Die sind ja so, weil wir da täglich mit zu tun haben. Nach drei Tagen machen wir da Witze drüber, weil es uns schon voll auf den Sack geht und weil wir es von vorne bis hinten kennen. Diese Sickerzeit wird immer kürzer bei den Leuten, weil die es auch eher gewöhnt sind, sowas zu sehen.
Ja gut, ich meine, dieser Krieg war ja nun immerhin schon seit ein paar Monaten angekündigt, dass er stattfindet. Das war natürlich beim World Trade Center ganz anders.
Ja, beim World Trade Center ist ja auch so ein Tor gewesen, das erst diese ganzen Diskussionen ermöglicht hat. Also Stefan Raab war eine Woche, bei September 2001 nicht zu sehen. Harald Schmidt hat irgendwie, glaube ich, einen halben Monat oder so nicht gesendet. Jetzt hat Stefan Raab nur drei Tage Pause gemacht, Harald Schmidt glaube ich gar nicht. Der hat dann gestern dafür die Korrespondenten ziemlich auseinandergenommen. Also ich glaube, die haben auch einfach in der Zeit seit dem Anschlag auf das World Trade Center ziemlich viel überlegt und auch diskutiert in der Szene auf den verschiedenen Kongressen, der Milch-Inbranche, Podiumsdiskussionen und so weiter, wie man damit umgeht. Und was mir halt aufgefallen ist, dass zum Beispiel BBC World heute zum ersten Mal wieder kleine Werbespots im Programm hatte, wo sie die ganze Zeit eigentlich statt der Werbung dann immer so mit ihrer Nachrichtenmusik unterlegte No-Comment-Bilder gezeigt haben, also ohne Sprecher. Und jetzt haben sie heute zum ersten Mal wieder so Werbung von südasiatischen Flugzeuglinien und so weiter im Programm gehabt, wo CNN eigentlich schon relativ früh wieder Teile von Werbung gezeigt hat, hauptsächlich Eigenwerbung, aber halt auch so diese üblichen, mit ihrem Wetterprogramm verknüpften Kooperationen. Und das finde ich halt dann schon irgendwie, denke mal, so eine Nachwirkung vom 11. September 2001 vom Anschlag auf das World Trade Center und der daraus folgenden Diskussion, was kann man machen, dass es halt jetzt schon so schnell wieder zum Rück zum Business oder Business as usual geht.
Es gab so eine Schätzung, so eine Geschichte, dass Fox Networks mit seinen ganzen Sendern und Senderfamilien in den ersten drei Tagen des Krieges, wo definitiv keine Werbung gesendet werden kann, aus Pietätsgründen, weil die Leute das nicht anerkennen würden, dass die 120 Millionen Verlust machen, 120 Millionen Dollar in den ersten drei Tagen.
Die Ausgaben für die Korrespondenten, die übrigens, das sei noch angemerkt, mittlerweile nur noch aus Freischaffenden stehen. Also kaum ein Sender hat noch hauptberuflich angestellte Leute da in der Region. Selbst die Nachrichtentechniker und Kameraleute sind alle abgezogen worden.
Aber feste Verträge haben die doch, ne?
Das weiß ich nicht. Also zum Beispiel der MDR-Mann Kloos oder wie der heißt, der sich ja jetzt so ein bisschen Kriegsberichterstattung ist ja immer auch Karriereleiter für Journalisten und Journalistinnen gewesen. Und das hat er ja auch in so einem Interview zugegeben. Der ist ja jetzt glaube ich auf mehreren Sendern drauf. Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass der MDR dem erlaubt, mit RTL oder anderen Sendern oder N24 war es glaube ich, irgendwelche festen Verträge zu machen. Dazu knebeln die deutschen Medienunternehmen ihre Freischaffenden doch zu sehr. Also das weiß ich jetzt nicht genau, weil ich kann es mir ehrlich gesagt nicht so recht vorstellen. Ja, bloß du hast dann kein Recht mehr an dem, was du da arbeitet hast, weil ja auch die Zweit- und Drittverwertung auf CD-ROM und Internet, das sind ja die ganzen Probleme, die freie Fotografen und freien Journalisten zurzeit haben. Da gab es halt den Tagesspiegelprozess und andere. Wie gesagt, dieser Krieg ist für die Medienlandschaften eine super interessante Sache. Guckt euch einfach mal im Internet um, macht dem Stichwort Medienjournalismus, da werdet ihr einiges finden. Da gibt es auch ein Webforum im Internet, wo sich darüber unterhalten wird über Kriegs- und Krisenberichterstattung. Ich denke mal, dass werden diese Kriegsachen so ein bisschen auf die Nerven gehen, aber der sich immer noch mit dem Thema beschäftigen will, Medienjournalismus ist dann, glaube ich, die Wahl dafür.
Okay, danke für den Tipp.
Ja, und Max, falls du Jan von Globion, Jason von Globion triffst, dann grüß dich mal schön von mir.
Vielen Dank, dass du angerufen hast.
Sub-Ether lebt.
Ich bin Robert, bin 16, komme aus Potsdam und ich finde es ziemlich mies, was der Busch da abzieht, weil jetzt war ein neuer Anlauf, der auch fast geklappt hätte mit den Inspektoren, lief an mit dem Waffenzerstören und auf einmal will er nun doch zuschlagen, nur weil ihm dieses Regime nicht passt. Und er hat keine breite Zustimmung, aus Deutschland zum Beispiel oder Frankreich, Russland und so. Und nun greift er einfach selbstständig an, gegen das Völkerrecht und das find ich mies.
Das war eine Meinung von hier und aus der Gegend. Wir warten auf deine Meinung unter www.fritztee.de und im Radio.
Wir hören das Chaos Radio auf, Fritz. Wir haben es kurz vor halb eins, das heißt wir haben noch eine gute halbe Stunde Zeit zu reden. Wie immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat stellt der Chaos Computer Club das Team hier im Studio. Andreas, Tim und meine Person Max Romalotky, guten Tag.
Toller Musik im Hintergrund gemixt von DJ Rolle, sollte man vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen.
Ist das denn irgendwas, was quasi als CD auch erhältlich ist oder?
Nö, das ist einfach ein Partymix. Das ist ein Mitschnitt von unserer Bye Bye Blinkenlights Party.
Bye Bye Blinkenlights. Wo sind denn Blinkenlights momentan eigentlich?
Na, die sind gerade in Miniaturversion am Haus des Lehrers im Bauschild untergebracht. Ansonsten ist das Projekt sozusagen gerade so ein bisschen im Pause-Modus, aber wir haben halt das Original Blinkenlights im Kleinen in das Bauschild. Weil das ist ja gerade Baustelle, das wird ja gerade alles umgebaut, im September neu eröffnet. Und da kann man auch Punktspielen, auch wenn man natürlich da keine Telefone mal kennt, weil wir denen noch keinen gesagt haben, da sind wir gerade noch so ein bisschen am Basteln.
Können wir die vielleicht hier so bekannt gegeben, so für Freunde und Hörer? Nö. Was ist eigentlich, ihr wart doch in Paris, ich dachte...
Aber auf linkenlights.de, ja, was ist in Paris gewesen?
Ihr wart doch in Paris mit dem Ding und ich dachte, ihr geht jetzt total international und dann seid ihr demnächst, was weiß ich, auch in USA, aber die wollen uns ja jetzt nicht mehr, oder vielleicht in Spanien, obwohl die wollen uns auch nicht mehr, in Italien vielleicht.
Die gehören doch auch zu den Bösen oder nicht?
Stimmt, die Italiener.
Na ja, das geht weiter, das Projekt, so viel, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, aber es gibt halt jetzt noch nichts Konkretes zum Ankündigen, aber wir haben jetzt erstmal genug damit zu tun gehabt, das letzte zu verarbeiten. Es gibt ein Dokumentationsvideo zum letzten Projekt in Paris unter www.blinkenlights.de slash video Da kann man sich auch das erste Doku-Video hier zu der Berliner Installation auch nochmal dazuholen, das sind so 14 Minuten in schön bunt. Und ja, die Installation hier in Berlin, die läuft zwar schon Anfang des Jahres, aber wir haben einfach gerade wenig Zeit gehabt, uns da wirklich darum zu kümmern. Wir wollen da nochmal ein bisschen was dran machen. So, basteln aber noch ein bisschen an der Software rum, bevor wir damit richtig loslegen.
Das läuft aber noch eine Weile, das läuft noch bis nächstes Jahr. Thema heute Abend allerdings, im Zeichen des Irakkrieges natürlich, Medien und Medienmanipulation bezüglich des Irakkriegs. Und ihr könnt anrufen, 073 97 1 1 0. Welche Medien ihr zum Beispiel tendenziell überhaupt noch glauben könnt oder ob ihr euch nur noch selber vertraut und eure Einschätzung meditiert, darüber Kaffeesatz lesen, was nutzt ihr? Am Telefon ist die Monika.
Ja, ich wollte also als erstes mal hinweisen, dass ich die erste Frau bin heute Abend. Aber mir. Genau, ich wollte noch mal darüber reden, wie die Medien auch mit den Gegenstimmen gegen den Irak auch umgehen. Es gibt ja eigentlich seit Monaten, seit einem Jahr mittlerweile auch eine Bewegung, die sich gegen diesen Krieg oder die versucht hat, diesen Krieg auch zu verhindern. So und was mir aufgefallen ist zum Beispiel, oder was ich auch gehört habe von Leuten, die in den USA aktiv gewesen sind, dass die erzählt haben, die ersten großen Demonstrationen in den USA sind von den Medien mehr oder weniger verschwiegen worden. Das heißt, die Zeitungen haben das irgendwo gebracht, auf den 20. Seiten oder so. Und es wurde gar nichts erzählt. Und erst die Demonstrationen in diesem Jahr sind wahrgenommen worden, sind aber sehr kritisch aufgenommen worden. Also die Leute wurden als Spinner, als unpatriotisch und so weiter abgestempelt. Genau und ich denke, auch hier in Deutschland ist es mir auch immer wieder aufgefallen, dass Anti-Kriegs-Aktivisten immer wieder als naiv dargestellt werden, als idealistisch und so weiter und so fort. Und dass die Argumente, die man also vorbringt, wenn man von Journalisten gefragt wird auf der Straße, ob das jetzt von Fernsehen oder von Kameraleuten oder einfach nur von Zeitungen begleitet ist, die immer wieder einem im Mund umgedreht werden.
Ist dir das jetzt persönlich passiert oder ist das jetzt auch wieder Hörensagen?
Das ist persönlich, ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau, weil ich meine Interviews nie gesehen habe. Ich hab sie mir einfach nicht angeguckt. Aber ich weiß, dass immer wieder solche Sachen passiert sind. Mir ist das auch vor einigen Jahren schon mehrmals passiert gewesen, dass ich irgendwie, als ich nach Genoa gefahren worden bin, von ARD interviewt worden bin und die haben gesagt, also die haben mich in einem falschen Kontext einfach zitiert. Und ja, genau. Es fiel so, als würde ich da hinfahren, um Radales zu machen.
Ja gut, dass ich meine in einem falschen Kontext zitiert werde, ist sicherlich ein Teil der Manipulation. Das ist natürlich auch immer das Problem generell, wenn man Interviews gibt. Viele verstehen das halt einfach gar nicht, was man sagt. Das kann an zwei Sachen liegen. Man will es nicht verstehen, man darf es nicht verstehen. Oder man hat es nicht verständlich gemacht.
Gut, aber wenn ein Satz zitiert wird, dann ist es sehr schwierig, in einem Satz was verständlich zu machen. Das schneiden sie sich dann sehr oft zurecht.
Die Hochkunst ist dann Sachen sozusagen, dass man sie nicht anders zurecht schneiden kann.
Aber es gibt sehr wenige, die das machen. Solche Kunst muss man ja erstmal erlernen. Das ist von den Massen der Menschen sehr viel erwartet, ehrlich gesagt. Die haben nur irgendwie einen Platz und über den Krieg und gerne was dagegen sagen würden. Was mir auch aufgefallen ist, ist heute zum Beispiel eine Berichterstattung gewesen von einer Kollegin vom Info-Radio über die EIS, die hier in Berlin leben. Was für eine Meinung die jetzt zu dem Krieg haben. Und es wurden einfach nur die EIS gefragt. Es wurden zwei Seiten gezeigt. Also hier eine Seite, die gesagt hat, wir unterstützen natürlich, dort ist der Abelbüsch und so und ich finde das richtig und stehen hinter ihm und so. Und dann wurde einer an einer interviewt, der war ein bisschen skeptischer, der nicht gesagt hat, ich unterstütze jetzt das vollkommen. Aber gut, Saddam muss auch irgendwie entwaffnet werden. Aber ich weiß zum Beispiel auch, dass es Vietnam Veterans Against War gibt. Das ist eine Koalition von EIS, die seit Ewigkeiten immer wieder Leute aufsammeln. Auch vom letzten Golfkrieg zum Beispiel. Die Desserteure versuchen, dem zu helfen. Die wurden zum Beispiel nicht gefragt. Es wurde auch nicht gesagt, dass es solche Leute gibt. Hier in Berlin. Die sehr, sehr viel. Also das wurde total unterbelichtet.
Es ist halt auch immer schwierig, alles was so an Wissen rumschwimmt, in einem Beitrag abzulichten. Die wollen natürlich auch immer einen Fokus haben. Ich meine, wir haben auch zum Beispiel zu Gast gehabt, hier im Blue Moon jemand, der im ersten Golfkrieg dabei war. Und der jetzt in Berlin lebt. Und der hier auch drei Stunden lang getalkt hat, den wir auch zu Gast hatten am Nachmittag. Das ist schon sehr, sehr schwierig. Das, was so einen Menschen bewegt, auch so auf dieser ganzen emotionalen Ebene, so innerhalb von drei Minuten mit einem Reportergespräch abzubilden, das ist quasi unmöglich. Und deswegen ist das immer so ein Kunststück, so einen Satz richtig zu zitieren, in den richtigen Kontext zu stellen. Und dann, wenn es gerade so heikel ist und so viele Parteien richtig gestimmt werden möchten, das ist superschwer. Deswegen gibt es ja auch so viele gute Journalisten nicht. Das sind ja nur so ein paar, die dann immer rumgereicht werden.
Aber man bekommt ja schon bei den Medien eher das Gefühl, dass sie sehr tendenziös sind. Also, ich meine, es ist ja selten so, dass gute Reportagen bei Demonstrationen kommen. Das ist tatsächlich auch das, was auf diesen Demonstrationen stattgefunden hat, auch berichtet wird. Also, wenn ich mir jetzt die Zeitungen angeguckt habe nach den großen Demonstrationen hier in Berlin, am Donnerstag und Samstag zum Beispiel, da waren das zum Teil, ich glaube, die Schülerdemo laut Polizeiangaben, da gab es auch in den Medien unterschiedliche Informationen, aber es waren so 50.000 bis 70.000 Leute. Und die Fotos, die dann da gewesen, also die abgebildet waren in den Zeitungen, waren sehr oft so Einzelpersonenfotos. So, die überhaupt diese Masse einfach, die da waren, nicht abgebildet haben. Und da fragt man sich, fragt man sich schon irgendwie, ob das nicht beabsichtigt ist. Also wenn man anfängt zu reflektieren, dass jetzt Z1 und ProSieben von einem US-amerikanischen Konzern nochmal aufgekauft worden ist, dass das Axelspringer Verlag sowieso nicht immer eine gute Rolle spielt.
Monika, wollen wir mal nicht zu viele Bereiche jetzt anschneiden und aufmachen, weil das ist natürlich ein weißes Feld und Spekulieren und solche Verschwörungstheorien aufzumachen, das kann man immer und ich weiß, wie verführerisch das ist. Ich mach das auch gerne, aber lass uns an dieser Stelle einfach mal Schluss machen. Ich denke, das ist Inspiration genug. Danke für deinen Anruf. Weil wir müssen auch Nachrichten machen. Mal sehen, ob wir das einigermaßen geradeaus kriegen.
Wenn Fritz rund um Cottbus, dann 103, 2.
Null Uhr, 8.33.
Mit dem Wetter.
In der Nacht erwarten uns immer mehr Wolken, aber wer weiß es genau. Bei Tiefstwerten zwischen 5 und 2 Grad, dass man nicht geschönt ist. Am Tag bleibt es wolkig, es gibt auch immer mal wieder Schauer. Die Temperaturen steigen auf fiktive 12 bis 16 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Berner. Britische und US-Truppen haben am späten Abend eine umfangreiche Militärkolonne der irakischen Armee im Süden von Basra aus der Luft angegriffen. Rund 120 Panzer, Artillerie und Transportwagen seien zuvor von der belagerten Millionstadt aus aufgebrochen, berichtet ein Journalist, der die britischen Truppen begleitet. Ein britischer Militär in Katar bestätigte, die irakische Kolonne bewege sich in Richtung der alliierten Stellung auf der Halbinsel V. Das militärische Ziel der Offensive sei bislang unklar. Die alliierten Truppen haben am Abend wieder die irakische Stadt Bagdad bombardiert. Reporter berichten von heftigen Explosionen in der Innenstadt. Im Laufe des Tages hatten alliierte Flugzeuge in Bagdad eine irakische Luftabwehrstellung unter Beschuss genommen. Laut dem US-Zentralkommando lag sie mitten in einem Wohngebiet. Zum Zeitpunkt der Bombardierung gab es in Bagdad eine Explosion in einer belebten Geschäftsstraße. Dabei wurden mindestens 15 Menschen getötet. Noch ist allerdings nicht sicher, dass die Explosion und die Bombardierung unmittelbar miteinander in Zusammenhang stehen. Südlich von Bagdad stoßen die alliierten Truppen nach wie vor auf heftigen Widerstand. Für den Neue Ostexperten Peter Schollertour ist klar, die Amerikaner haben taktische Fehler gemacht. Er sagte am Abend im ZDF.
Es ist erstaunlich, wie falsch die Psychologie des Landes eingeschätzt worden ist. Die Amerikaner haben wohl auch vergessen, dass die Sanktionen, die über das Land verhängt worden sind, von der Bevölkerung doch sehr schmerzlich empfunden worden sind. Auch wenn sie Salam Hussein nicht mochten oder ihn hassen. Man kann diese langen Nachschublinien, die entstanden sind, ja nur halten, wenn man eine halbwegs freundliche Bevölkerung im Umkreis hat. Das ist eben nicht der Fall.
US-Präsident Bush hat seine Landsleute auf einen längeren Krieg im Irak vorbereitet. Er hielt am Abend eine Rede auf einem Luftwaffen-Stützpunkt in Florida. Martin Wagner berichtet.
Meile um Meile kommen wir Bagdad, kommen wir dem Sieg näher. Siegesgewiss und selbstbewusst äußerte sich der amerikanische Präsident. Immer wieder vom Beifall der Soldaten unterbrochen, sagte Bush. Der Weg, den wir beschritten haben, ist nicht einfach. Und möglicherweise lang vor Bagdad stünden dem amerikanischen Militär verzweifelte Einheiten eines zum Untergang verdammten Regimes gegenüber.
Und zum Sport und zum Fußball in der 2.
Bundesliga hat Union Berlin in einem Nachholspiel gegen Reutlingen 0 zu 0 gespielt. Und der Verkehr auf Fritz hat keine Meldung, deswegen gute Fahrt.
Fritz, die Musik zum Kochen, Aufräumen, Joggen, Fußball, Kulfpück, Einschlafen, Reisen, Abschied und allem Möglichen. Mixtape, die Sendung für deinen ganz persönlichen Musikgeschmack. Und wenn du am Samstag dein Mixtape hören willst, www.fritz.de slash Mixtape. Jede Woche neu, jede Woche anders, jede Woche samstags von 18 bis 20 Uhr. Und im Radio Fritz.
Ihr hört aus Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat wird immer eine Sendung gestiftet, könnte man so sagen, vom Chaos Computer Club. Im Studio vom Chaos Computer Club Andreas und Tim, meine Person Max Farmalotki. Schönen guten Abend. Wir haben noch 20 Minuten Zeit zu talken mit euch hier im Lumun auf Fritz. Und wenn ihr teilnehmen möchtet, Thema ist natürlich wichtig. 80. Sendung des Chaos Radios beschäftigt sich heute Abend mit Medien und Medienmanipulation im Irak-Krieg. Und viele Sachen sind heute Abend schon angeschnitten worden. Und viele Sachen sind, wenn man so will, mehr Mythen als das, was man so unter objektiver Berichterstattung versteht. Und da gibt es natürlich dann auch so einige Sachen, wo alle irgendwie ganz entsetzt aufwarten und sich überlegen, ob sie überhaupt noch im Irak Berichterstattung machen können, Andreas.
Ja, das ist natürlich immer eine Möglichkeit, Leute dazu zu bringen, etwas zu tun oder nicht zu tun. Manchmal werden die auch direkt bedroht. Es gibt den Fall einer Reporterin der BBC, Katie Aidy heißt die, der tatsächlich gesagt wurde, ja, wenn du jetzt hier losgehst und deine eigene Satellitenstrecke verwendest, um zu berichten, dann kann es sein, wenn dein Flugzeug vorbeifliegt und du sendest da, dass wir da einfach drauf schießen. Also wurde unverblümt damit gedroht, wer unabhängig Berichterstattung macht, auf den schießen wir hier im Irak. Also es gibt nicht nur das subtile malen Informationen reinschieben oder das Modell Bestechung, sondern es gibt auch das Modell Bedrohung.
Nun können die sich natürlich aus der Affäre ziehen, indem sie dann sagen, ihr könnt ja eure Embedded Correspondence bei uns unterbringen und ihr habt ja alle Möglichkeiten bei uns mitzumachen. Warum wollt ihr eigentlich überhaupt alleine senden? Ich meine, das ist natürlich sehr, sehr heuchlerisch, aber trotzdem ist es eine Argumentation, die die natürlich gebracht haben.
Ja, natürlich. Der Reporter, der tatsächlich berichtet, das ist ja im Prinzip der ganze Knackpunkt. Den muss man dazu bringen, dass er etwas Bestimmtes sagt oder etwas Bestimmtes tut oder über etwas Bestimmtes nicht berichtet. Und die Bandbreite ist da einfach sehr, sehr groß, mit der das gemacht wird. So irgendwie, ja, geh da nicht hin, dahinten, da ist es gefährlich und überhaupt haben wir hier schöne Bilder für dich und halt mal die Kamera dahin, weil da kommen gleich die Irakis mit der weißen Fahne und ergeben sich. Und ich fand es auch sehr erstaunlich, also nicht die pixeligen, grünen Bilder, die, okay, man hat nichts drauf gesehen, aber da hat man wenigstens gesehen, dass es irgendwie halbwegs noch real ist. Und demgegenüber sieht man dann die Aufnahmen. Also, habt ihr das Bildtisch vor mir, diese sich ergebnenen Irakis. Und das war halt irgendwie unglaublich hohe Qualität, also in hoher Qualität gedreht. Die ganze Bildkomposition war prima und das war auch hinterher prima zusammengeschnitten. Da müsste bloß noch so ein bisschen patriotische Musik drunter liegen und dann hätte das Original aus einem Werbespot kommen können. Die ist mir halt auch aufgefallen, dass die Bilder manchmal auch zu perfekt waren, dass das eher Geschichten sind, wenn man gesagt hat, das kann jetzt aber nicht stimmen.
Aber was mich wundert ist, wie weit gibt es da Vermutungen, dass das, ich kann mir eigentlich immer nicht vorstellen, dass das alles Reporter sind, die so eingebettet sind und die irgendwelchen regierungsnahen Medien angehören. Das sind doch zum Teil auch Sachen, die bestimmt das Militär mit irgendwelchen Leuten selber dreht, dass diese Leute niemandem auffallen, die da in Militäruniformen rumlaufen und dann im Grunde da Aufnahmen machen. Sowas muss es doch geben, sowas muss doch irgendjemand mal gesehen haben.
Ja, und es gibt sicherlich auch eigene Kamera- und Dokumentationsteams, die da sind, die dann das entsprechende Bildmaterial einfach an die Agenturen liefern. Also das hört ja bei dem Reporter nicht auf, die Manipulationskette, sondern das geht ja auch in die Redaktion vor Ort rein, bis hin dahin, dass die Leute Angst haben, ihren Job zu verlieren, wenn sie irgendwie in einer bestimmten Art und Weise berichten oder nicht berichten. So Manipulation ist ja immer sehr subtil. Genauso wie das ist mit den Reportern, die versuchen, den Iraqi von der Straße zu interviewen. Da ist kein Reporter unterwegs, neben dem da nicht ein Geheimdienstmann steht. Und wenn da ein Geheimdienstmann steht, dann erzählen die Leute auf der Straße natürlich was völlig anderes, als sie einem unter vier Augen erzählen würden. Das ist also ein Spiel, das beide Seiten betreiben, wodurch durch das Auslösen von Ängsten quasi Leute dazu gebracht wurden, sich anders zu verhalten, als sie sich normalerweise verhalten würden.
Am Telefon ist der Micha aus Berlin, namens Micha.
Ja, hallo.
Ah, du bist noch da, Gott sei Dank. Ich dachte schon, vielleicht hättest du dich rausgehauen, weil du so lange warten musstest. Dein Beitrag zum Thema.
Ja, das sind endlich so zwei, naja, ich sag zweieinhalb Punkte direkt zum Thema. Und das erste ist, man muss sich das ja mal von der anderen Seite vorstellen und zwar von den Leuten, die jetzt manipulieren wollen. Was die im Prinzip für eine enorme Aufgabe haben, für ein enormes Volumen, was sie denn manipulieren müssten. Und das Problem wird sicherlich für die sein, erst mal alles abzudecken. Und vor allen Dingen auch in der relativ kurzen Zeit, da ja ziemlich viel, ziemlich schnell passiert, nur wirklich sich untereinander abzusprechen und nur wirklich eine hieb- und stichfeste Manipulation hinzulegen. Und da merkt man eben oft, dass es ziemlich das Problem ist, das hat man eben gesehen oder gehört bei diesen Meldungen, dass bestimmte Städte gefallen sind. Und genau bei solchen Beiträgen sollte man natürlich dann hellhörig werden und sagen, na ja, hier ist wohl offenbar mal was durch die Zensur oder durch die Manipulation vielleicht mal durchgerutscht, dass man wirklich darauf spezifisch ein Auge hat. Und das ist halt was, wo man vielleicht ein bisschen sich da auch rausiegeln kann aus dieser Manipulationskiste. Das ist erstmal das Erste. Und den zweiten Punkt, der mir aufgefallen ist, dass man durchaus auch Vergleiche anstellen muss zu Informationen, die man von früher hat. Zum Beispiel von den Büchern von dem Herrn Scholler-Tur, durchaus in einer Zeit entstanden sind, wo diese Zensur und diese Manipulation ja eigentlich noch gar nicht aktuell waren. Und man im Nachhinein darauf kommt, bestimmte Sachen können so eigentlich gar nicht richtig stimmen oder sollten eigentlich anders abgelaufen sein, als sie jetzt dargestellt wären. Und man sollte diese Polarinformation dann auch durchaus nutzen, wenn es denn irgendwie möglich ist.
Ja, ich denke, das ist richtig, dass man immer versuchen muss, die Quellen sich anzugucken, Quellen versuchen muss, selber nochmal nachzuvollziehen, um so ein bisschen ein Gefühl dafür zu kriegen, was jetzt irgendwie komplett erfunden ist und wo ein bisschen Wahrheit dran sein kann. Ich denke, was wirklich passiert ist, wird man nie rausfinden können. Man wird immer bloß sehen können, ah, die lügen und die auf der anderen Seite lügen auch. Das ist das Einzige, wovon wir ausgehen können, ist, dass da Leute sterben.
Es gibt auch noch so andere Aspekte. Ich meine, wenn bestimmte Quellen von vornherein ausgeschaltet werden können, dann wird das natürlich auch betan. Man kann sich zum Beispiel fragen, warum gibt es eigentlich keine detaillierten Satellitenbilder vom Irak jeden Tag? Weil da fliegen mittlerweile dermaßen viele private Satelliten über dieses Land und können auf den Meter genau Bilder liefern. Die tun das natürlich auch. Bloß das Problem ist, dass alle Bilder von der US-Regierung aufgekauft werden und nicht veröffentlicht werden. Das heißt, es erschlagen die einfach mal mit Geld.
Na gut, da hab ich schon etwas als Verständnis für. Aber es ist natürlich klar, dass bei so einer Militäraktion die ihren taktischen Vorteil auch zu behalten und den Irakis da vielleicht nicht noch Informationen zu liefern, die letztlich gegen sie verwendet werden. Das ist aus militärtaktischer Sicht mir eigentlich völlig klar. Klar, ist mir auch klar. Oftmals hilft der gesunde Menschenverstand, wo man dann wirklich kombinieren kann, was sein kann, was nicht. Zum Beispiel, bloß die Information, dass anstatt vor Anfang des Krieges 45% der Amerikaner nur für einen Krieg waren, jetzt sind es immer 60% oder gar mehr. Das ist eine Information, die sehr leicht fälschen lässt. Und dahingehend würde ich auch sagen, dass es voll der Blödsinn ist. Ich habe selber eine E-Way gelesen, die an einen Professor an der Charité geschickt wurde, wo dann eben auch drin stand, das ist direkt von einem Amerikaner. Und der hat dann eben auch geschrieben, dass das ziemlich der Blödsinn ist. Es sind immer noch total viele Leute, wirklich gegen den Krieg. Und ja, da muss man immer wirklich trennen, welche Informationen lassen sich wirklich sehr leicht manipulieren, wie zum Beispiel so eine Meinungsumfrage. Das ist ja auch für die Amerikaner wichtig, dass sie sagen können hier Leute, unsere eigenen Menschen, 60 Prozent oder zwei Drittel sind halt für den Krieg. Warum auch du nicht so ungefähr in der Art und Weise?
Ich glaube keiner Statistik, die du nicht selbst gefälscht hast. Das ist glaube ich so ein Standardsatz in jeder Statistik Vorlesung, wenn man sich damit halbwegs wissenschaftlich auseinandersetzt. Meine Meinungsumfragen glaubt gerade, die heute in den Medien verbreiteten. Sind sie für oder dagegen, rufen sie uns jetzt an, 0, 90 Tralala, anruf nur 49 Cent. Also ich meine, da spiegelt sich die Meinung wieder. Und auch diese anderen Meinungsforschungsinstitute sind auch häufig genug irgendwie auf die Nase gefallen mit irgendwelchen Punkten.
Ich weiß es selber, weil ich arbeite nämlich selber bei so einem Meinungsforschungsinstitut. Ich hab mich da auch ausgewiescht, und dann muss ich mit dem Max-Knopf darüber mal irgendwie thermell unterhalten.
Und hast du jetzt auch solche Umfragen gerade gemacht?
Direkt zu dem Irak-Krieg noch nie. Es sind immer Fragen untergestreut zu verschiedene, die dann allerdings, glaube ich, nicht wirklich Aussagen treffen. Das ist das, was man vielleicht zum Fokus, glaube ich, kommt da manchmal an Sachen. Neben der Sonntagsfrage eben auch mal, wie viele Leute für oder gegen den Irak-Krieg sind, oder welche Leute sich dann halt in ihren Urlaubsplänen beeinflusst fühlen. Und in welcher Art und Weise. Es lässt allerdings nicht viel Aussage zu. Aber man bekommt sicherlich aus meiner Sicht dann schon ein bisschen mehr ein Auge dafür, was wirklich wirklich leicht falschen lässt und was nicht. Und ich halte mich dann eben mehr an die Informationen, die sich wirklich nicht so leicht falschen lassen.
Wobei man da auch ein bisschen aufpassen muss, das wird schon im großen Stil betrieben. Solche Operationen laufen unter dem Titel Psychological Warfare. Und da gibt es tatsächlich ganze Abteilungen, die sich darum kümmern und die auch über viel Geld verfügen, um so was gezielt zu betreiben. Also nur weil etwas so aussieht, als wäre es nicht so leicht zu falschen, heißt es noch lange nicht, dass es nicht falschbar ist.
Das ist sicher. Man muss ja irgendwie, bei dieser Ernstungsflussung und Informationen muss man erst mal eine Vorauswahl treffen. Man muss erst mal wirklich die absolut unwahrscheinlichen Sachen kann man schon mal rausschmeißen. Da wird es schon mal ganz schön viel weniger. Da hat man wesentlich weniger, was man durchzuhackern hat. Und ich mache zum Beispiel so Spiegellese halt und schneide mir die Artikel, die ich denke, die brauche ich vielleicht später nochmal oder kann ich später nochmal lesen, einfach wirklich raus, hefte die ab und dann, wenn man die im Nachhinein sich nochmal durchliest, da erkennt man dann, ah, hier ist es wirklich so eingetroffen, wie es dort prophezeit war, was dort geschrieben wurde. Wenn man sich den Artikel dann nochmal durchliest, dann kann man eben wirklich sagen, ja, das sind eben Informationen, die nicht unter diese massive Manipulation gefallen sind. Und aufgrund dessen kann man sich dann ein Bild machen und sich natürlich auch selber einen Kopf machen. Das ist dann schon in deren Sicht vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher, als wenn man immer nur die live Sachen einbezieht in seine derzeit ja Meinungsbildung.
Ja, das war ganz nett. Wir haben natürlich auch mal geguckt, was gibt es so für Quellen in Amerika. Es gibt ein amerikanisches Meinungsforschungsinstitut, wo wir jetzt gerade mal bei dem Thema sind. Gallup heißen die, relativ bekannt. Das findet man unter www.gallup.com, also Gallup. Die veröffentlichen ja auch relativ häufig so Sachen. Wie du ja schon gesagt hast, klar kann man den Sachen nicht vertrauen, aber so, da du ja in dem Bereich auch arbeitest, wirst du ja auch immer wissen, was kann man denn daran, selbst wenn das so gefälscht sein sollte, tendenziell ablesen, wenn man möchte, beziehungsweise in welche Richtung geht da etwaige Beeinflussung. Das war ganz lustig, das war damals eine Umfrage. Da ging es darum, sind sie für oder gegen den Krieg? Und dann gings dann da 60% dafür, 40% dagegen. Aber mit der Zusatzfrage, warum jetzt eigentlich genau? Und da ging es dann darum, dass dann 30% von denen, die dafür waren, also nicht von denen, die dafür waren, sondern 30% von den 100% gesagt haben, naja, jetzt sind wir sowieso schon dabei, jetzt müssen wir da auch durch. Und das ist das, was wir in der Sendung ja heute schon mal hatten, dieses Ding. Da müssen unsere Jungs, ist der eine Faktor, und die müssen da jetzt schnell durch. Und dieser Krieg soll so schnell wie möglich wieder zu Ende gehen. Also diese Augenverschließtaktik ist, wo man auch gemerkt hat, die sind jetzt nicht unbedingt dafür, die wollen dann nur relativ schnell wieder raus. Also die wollen die Situation an sich nicht und wählen jetzt das geringere Übel, nämlich nicht, wir sind dagegen und versuchen es jetzt nur abzuwenden, geht eh nicht mehr, sondern wir wollen wieder weg davon. Und das war ganz spannend zu beobachten, dass diese 60-40-Kiste nicht so super aussagekräftig ist, ist klar. Aber dass man ungefähr weiß, was für ein Stimmungsumschwung findet da gerade in der Bevölkerung statt.
Ja, das ist wirklich wichtig, diese Kontextfragen, die zu dieser zentralen Frage meistens gestellt werden, wenn es wirklich eine vernünftige Umfrage ist. Und wenn diese dann halt mit abgedruckt werden, man sich vielleicht ein Bild daraus machen kann, wie denn die Aussage aus der zentralen Frage zu bewerten ist, das ganze Umfeld von der Frage, wie die eben auch gestellt wird. Und man muss auch darauf achten, dass wenn man sich so eine Sache durchliest und daraus Informationen bezieht, auch wirklich die komplette Fragestellung halt mit drüber gebracht wird, wenn das eben nicht so ist, dann kann man sich wirklich selber daraus nicht so viel entnehmen.
Vor allen Dingen eine, ich muss mal ganz kurz sagen, das ist fast schon Satire, was jetzt hier gerade passiert ist. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr mal vorbeigesurft seid bei Gallup. Diese Umfrage, die hier gerade läuft, die muss man eigentlich mal vortragen, weil sowas bringen eigentlich auch nur die Amerikaner. Und zwar geht es um die Umfrage. Die Umfrage heißt, ich lese es mal auf Englisch vor, dann kann ich es nämlich für mich besser übersetzen. Actions taken by Americans as a result of the beginning of the Persian Gulf War und September 11's terrorist attacks. Da wird also verglichen, was die Amerikaner so unternommen haben als Ergebnis des Golfkrieges und als Ergebnis vom 11. September. Und da wird tatsächlich verglichen, und zwar sind das drei Werte. Zum einen, a, ich habe die amerikanische Flagge öfter gezeigt, b, ich habe mehr gebetet als normal, und c, ich habe geweint. Und jetzt kommt der Vergleich. Wegen des 11. Septembers haben 82% ihrer amerikanische Flagge gezeigt. Wegen des Golfkrieges nur 56%. Mehr als normal gebetet haben 74% beim 11. September. Beim Irakkrieg scheint ja nicht so schlimm zu sein, nur 52%. Und jetzt geweint, da steht einfach nur CRIED drunter, haben wegen des 11. Septembers 79% und wegen des Irakkrieges 28%. Das ist ja fast schon eine Faas, diese Umfrage. Geht ja gar nicht.
Du bist hier auch ganz sicher, dass da irgendwo in der Adresseite nicht irgendwo Eulenspiegel oder so auftaucht?
Nee, also, das ist die amerikanische Adresseite.
Muss man denn hier draufklicken? Ich find das gerade nicht.
Das ist also gallup.com, gallup.com und dann eigentlich auf den Hauptartikel, der da so in der Mitte schwimmt. Da ist noch nicht viel zu sehen.
Ja, ich weiß, die ist dann schon pervertierte Blödheit.
War makes Americans confident, sad.
Ja, ja, okay, jetzt hab ich's auch begriffen.
War und dann ein bisschen tiefer. Also das sind solche Sachen, da fragt man sich tatsächlich, wer denkt sich solche Umfragen aus? Das müssen ja echt ein paar Scherzkeksl sein.
Ja, das ist durchaus richtig. Ich finde es schon wirklich pervers, wie billig manchmal die Manipulationen sind. Also ich meine, irgendwie die Leute machen das aus irgendeinem bestimmten Grund und mit einem bestimmten Ziel, aber halten die einen wirklich zu dermaßen bescheuert. Ich meine, ich finde das wirklich schon teilweise echt beleidigend und ja, man kann halt leider nichts machen. Ich kann deshalb niemand irgendwie an die Gurgel springen oder so, aber es ist doch einzig...
Sie würden es nicht machen, wenn es dafür keine Zielgruppe gibt. Ich meine, mit so etwas kriegt man natürlich ohne irgendetwas zu behaupten, einfach einen klaren Bezug zwischen dem 11. September und diesem Golfkrieg hin, der ja, in so einer Mehrheitsauffassung, eigentlich was miteinander ist.
Ja, aber dann muss man ja wirklich schon, sagt man, ein sehr enges Bezugsystem irgendwie haben.
Das entsteht einfach durch den Kontext der Frage. So, da, jetzt passiert sozusagen irgendwie im ähnlichen Kontext, verhältst du dich auch ähnlich oder nicht? Und damit wird das halt suggeriert. Ich meine, viele Amerikaner glauben einfach, diese Propaganda, dass Irak irgendwas mit Al-Qaeda zu tun hat, wo man halt irgendwie ganz klar sehen kann, da hat man irgendwie auf der einen Seite islamischen Fundamentalisten, der anderen Seite irgendwie arabische Nationalisten, die irgendwie einfach mal exakt genau das Gegenkonzept zu den Fundamentalisten darstellen und die irgendwie in einen Topf zu werfen, ist halt einfach billig.
Dazu muss man allerdings sagen, denke ich, dass wirklich die Amerikaner ja jetzt nicht nur in den letzten Wochen und Monaten unter dieser massiven Einflussung stehen, sondern eigentlich schon ihr Leben lang wird sie noch nicht mal wirklich zu übel nehmen von der Sache her. Weil die hören wirklich überhaupt nichts anderes. Ich meine, sicherlich habt ihr auch hier Rolling for Columbine gelesen oder Stupid White Men. Da kann man sich dann wirklich schon draußen nehmen. Für mich wäre das echt die Hölle, weil ich das überhaupt nicht kenne. Ich würde damit wirklich nicht klarkommen mit dieser ganzen ständigen Gehirnwäsche. Aber die Leute kennen das halt nicht anders.
Na gut, das ist aber glaube ich ein bisschen hart. Ich glaube, das tut jetzt so, als wäre das ein komplett verdummtes Volk. 95% von denen wissen nicht, wie man das Alphabet zu Ende buchstabiert. Ich glaube aber, dass das, was wir vorhin auch hatten, nämlich dieser Punkt, dass die Leute sagen, ich will, dass der Krieg schnell zu Ende geht, jetzt wo er angefangen hat, dass eher und schneller, wenn die Leute merken, ey, ihr wollt mich wohl für absolut dumm verkaufen, dass die Leute eher voll von Resignationen sind und sagen, ey, lass mich einfach in Ruhe damit. Hör auf, anstatt dass sie eine Wut entwickeln, weil sie damit in Ruhe gelassen wollen. Und das sind bestimmt 30% der Leute.
Ja, das ist richtig. Aber was du gerade gesagt hast, dass 90% der Leute so dumm sind. Ich sag ja nicht, dass sie dumm sind. Es ist einfach bloß aus Mangel an wirklich, braucht man Informationen, können sie sich einfach nicht so ein konkretes Bild machen. Und in dem Fritzbord wurde es auch schon mal hingeschrieben, dass, glaube ich, wie war es ja, 40%, ich hab das nämlich auch gesehen, diese Umfrage, die da gemacht wurde, 40% oder nur 40% der Amerikaner wirklich wissen, dass Donald Rumsfeld der Verteidigungsminister ist. Und ich meine, das ist ja nun schon von der Sache her aussagekräftig egal, was da nun drum um ist, aber wenn wirklich nur 40% der Amerikaner wissen, dass Donald Rumsfeld ihr Verteidigungsminister ist und der ist ja auch dort relativ oft in Fernsehen zu sehen und gibt dann nun seine Statements zum Besten.
Also in Anbetracht der Tatsache, dass nur 20% ihn überhaupt dazu gewählt haben, finde ich total 40% schon ziemlich beeindruckend.
Wie gewählt? Gewählt noch nicht ihr Verteidigungsminister, oder?
Also ich meine, durch ihre konkrete Stimmabgabe dazu beigetragen haben, dass er Verteidigungsminister wird.
Ach so, ja.
Also das ist halt ungefähr die Wahlbeteiligung in den USA.
Ja, ich hin und wieder, wie gesagt, lese ich auch mal so E-Mails, die so an der Uni so vertelt werden von Leuten, die sie aus Amerika irgendwie kennen. Und da scheint dann eben auch wirklich durch das eine enorme Diskrepanz zwischen Leuten, die sich interessieren und auch wirklich versuchen, an Informationen ranzukommen. Und eben die große Masse, die, wie du gesagt hast, einfach gesagt haben, lasst mich einfach in Ruhe mit dem ganz schönen Scherz, das kürzt mich einfach an und denen, das zu viel ist, sich wirklich damit auseinandersetzen, weil das dort wesentlich schwieriger ist, sich ein ordentliches Bild zu machen, als es noch bei uns der Fall ist.
Ja, hoffen wir das mal. Hoffen wir, dass wir auch, dass wir noch in der Lage sind, über unsere eigenen Tellerränder drüber wegzugucken und dass wir es irgendwo noch merken. Weil vielleicht merken wir es ja auch nicht. Vielleicht ist das System, was uns umgibt, einfach besser ausgeklügelt als das der Amerikaner. Wer weiß es?
Kann ich zum Abschluss noch ein Statement machen? Das habe ich mal im Fernsehen gesehen und der Spruch hieß, glaube, höre alles, glaube wenig, sage nichts. Aus Star Trek war das übrigens eine amerikanische Serie. Ja, vielleicht nicht ganz so jetzt der Bezugspunkt, aber ich finde es doch schon recht passend.
Vielen Dank. Das wollen wir einfach mal als Abschluss nehmen, weil wir sind im Grunde auch am Ende der Sendung angelangt. Dank dir für den Anruf. Ja, ihr könnt auch weiter diskutieren. Wir haben ja ein Irak Board eingerichtet bei Fritz. www.fritz.de slash boards und da aufs Irak Board. Da könnt ihr dann im Grunde die ganze Alternativinformation unterbringen.
Was wird das auch für Blinde?
Wir geben uns ja schon Mühe. Das referiert jetzt auf eine andere Sendung sozusagen, bei der uns ein Blinder-Mithörer angerufen hat, der gesagt hat, dass unsere Seite, also das war die Quintessenz, das Ganze für Blinde nicht so wirklich kompatibel ist. Wir arbeiten an allem, an allen Fronten, um meinem Duktus jetzt zu bleiben. Das war es im Grunde. Alle anderen, die jetzt nicht mehr durchkommen bei uns unter unserer Hotline, sorry, aber wir sind am Ende der Sendung angelangt. Das 80. Chaosradio geht zu Ende. Und im Studio Andreas, Tim und Max, wir sagen im Grunde Tschüss. Wir sagen im Grunde Tschüss.
Das war 80. Chaosradio Sendung.
Richtig.
Gar nicht so schlecht, oder?
Ja, ich bin auch, also ich bin gerade auch so ein bisschen stolz.
Wir halten uns wacker.
Ja, ich find's ganz geil. Und es kommt bestimmt auch die 81. Wie gesagt, immer jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, auch so den nächsten letzten, könnte wieder einschalten. Und wir geben hier ab und legen euch vertrauensvoll in die Hände von Martin Petersdorf, der jetzt musikalisch den Nightflight höchstwahrscheinlich sehr, sehr gut bestreiten wird. Wie das übrigens der Rechner von Tim auch die ganze Zeit getan hat mit diesem wunderbaren DJ-Set, das wir jetzt gegen Ende nochmal aufblenden, wa? Tschüss, macht's gut. Achso, und wenn es Reso gibt, also Resonanz, 80at chaosradio.ccc.de ist die E-Mail-Adresse. Da könnt ihr hinschreiben, wenn ihr möchtet.
80 nicht ACH und so weiter.
Achso, nicht das komplizierte. Das einfache.
Also Ziffer-Ad sozusagen.
Genau. Das endet hier ins Runde bitte.
Ach Jungs, bis nächsten Letzten.
Achtung! Die folgende Information wurde nicht von US-Zensurbehörden freigegeben.